foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
good morning everyone and welcome to the
town hall biddyford and for those
members of the public who are joined us
joining us on YouTube This is the first
meeting of the plans committee since the
recent council elections
there is no planned fire drill for this
morning so if the alarm does go off
please leave the building the way that
you came up the stairs and please do not
use the lift
we have some returning committee members
and some fresh faces on the committee
and I'm sure that we can work well
together for the benefit of the whole of
torridge and we always have expert and
available support from our officers so
please use their expertise
I'll stay easy to run through for those
members how to use your microphones and
how to record your vote
so good good morning everyone
um so can I ask members when they do
want to speak can they please switch the
microphones on and then it ensures uh
those viewing on YouTube can hear and
everyone in the room can hear
um the microphone it's the mic button so
if you press that then when it comes on
when it's ready to go it all flash green
for you
um can I ask if you want to speak can
you please um put your hands up and in
the chair we'll come to you in order and
the other thing which we don't usually
do will always do on other committees is
we always take a recorded vote for plans
committee so the committee Clarks Sandra
when the proposal and the second air has
been made will go through each of you
and ask if you're voting for or against
thank you for that stay easy so I'd just
like to go around the room and ask
counselors to introduce themselves for
the benefit of everyone State their name
and the wall that they represent so if I
can start with councilor Haynes
right good morning my name is Peter
Christie I represent Biddeford North
good morning my name is Christopher
Wheatley I represent shabia and Langtry
Philip Pennington monthly and putford
Stephen Gibson
I've forgotten
I'm so new broadheath
thank you Philip that'll be in the
journey
councilor Chris leather and I represent
Northern
and I've got the Rosemary lock and I
represent two rivers and three Moors and
can I ask the officers to introduce
themselves starting from this end
morning I'm Stacey Dory I'm head of
legal governance
good morning I'm Helen Smith the
planning manager
good morning Laura Davis development
management team leader
right if you never like to turn to your
agenda item number one apologies please
thank you chair two apologies councilor
heppo substituting his counselor Hackett
and councilor Whitaker apologies
councilor Gibson substituting
thank you very much so idle number two
to receive the minutes of the meeting
held
30th of March 2023 but looking at the
attendance for these this meeting there
are only three members here today that
can actually make any comments on the
minutes
so any comments on the minutes
yes Pennington eight second paragraph
um it does say due to the conduct of the
public I would like that change to do to
a small number of the members of the
public because certain people got
excluded from that meeting who behaved
perfectly well and I don't want them to
be included in the catch-all phrase so I
asked them to change them in it to a
small number of the members of the
public not due to the public
yeah
so with that with that um Amendment
could we have a show of hands yes
and it's not actually about the planning
um I have asked that the officers do a
presentation to the counselors a lot of
the new ones about the environment
Center just to bring them up to date
with what's happening up there because
we know it became very contentious
during the election and it would be nice
to have an update on it for the new
councilors
I'm sure the officers will organize
something for that kind of question so
can we have a show of hand for those
people who can approve the minutes
this kind of times I know I wasn't here
but it's just thinking of some member of
the public and clarification it's page
four at the top and seven at the bottom
second paragraph possibility
possibilities smells councilor Christie
asked whether a negative atmosphere
could be included on the side
um I find it's quite a bizarre sort of
statement um
does this mean there's a possibility
that there could be a problem of smells
on the site it seems to read rather
strangely it's only a small point
does everyone else understand
I think
it says in the minute it says Council
Christie asks whether a negative
atmosphere could be included on the site
which I found bizarre statement that
obviously no one else does
respond
of green
um yeah this came up many many years ago
when Southwest water built their
um sewage plant down by Riverbank the
building has a negative atmosphere I.E
the smells can't escape
that's the idea uh unfortunately for
those staff members who work down there
I don't know if it works now but it did
work when it started and as it was
raised during the debate I thought it
was worth just raising that possibility
um just to have a look see if it was
possible Council names I think that's a
matter you can discuss outside I'm sorry
this Committee in the minutes yeah
so a show of hands to those who can
approve the minutes
three abstentions
sorry Chad we're going to need a
proposal in a second uh for the minute
all right a proposed one promoters the
minutes are adopted
in the second though
Council leather all those in favor
three
abstentions
but yeah that's right yeah
all right at number three Declarations
of Interest members with interest to
declare should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interests when the item is being
considered elected members of DCC and
town and Parish councils who have
considered a plan in application by
virtue of their membership at that
Council hold a personal interest and our
deemed to have considered the
application separately and the express
view is that that council do not bind
the members concern who consider the
application of fresh which may include
further information
item number five agreements of the
agenda between Parts one and two we have
no part twos
urgent matters I have none Helen do you
ever need Stacy no urgent matters
item number six public participation the
order of speaking is
a member of the town or Parish Council
two members of the public in support
two members of the public against
all of the above have three minutes each
and finally the world member may speak
and they are not limited to three
minutes so I will read out the names of
those who have registered to speak when
we come to their particular application
so now we go on to the main part of the
agenda the planning applications
so your first application is
reference number one stroke 063 to 21 22
dwellings at bradworthy which is on
pages
21-51 of your agenda are there any
Declarations of Interest
not
the officer will now get the
presentation
thank you chair
this is an application which is made in
outline for up to 22 dwellings with all
matters reserved except for the access
which is provided detail for land west
of North Road bradworthy members will be
aware that the application was
previously considered by the plans
committee at the time
in December 2021
so we have just run through the slides
we've got the application site outlined
in red
there which forms part of an existing
agricultural field so it's located
immediately to the north of bradworthy
we have residential dwellings to
Tucker's Park and to North Road to the
South open agricultural land to the
north and to the west and some existing
developments that are taking place to
the east on the opposite side of North
Road
move on to I think there's an aerial
photograph
we're working with a bit of a delay so
just to show the application site on an
aerial Imaging context of the existing
development in bradworthy so the arrow
indicating roughly where the site is
and then moving on
to the next slide please
we've got this is an extract from the
local plans policy map for bradworthy so
just to make glitter members where the
settlement boundary is for Brad worthy
and this site isn't located immediately
to the north of that and outside of the
settlement boundary
we'll move on to some photographs so
this is taken looking South across the
site from the existing field Gate
entrance so towards the dwellings at
Tucker's Park
and then scanning around to the
Southwest
I'm looking to the West
and then up to the northwest of the site
you can see it's largely level
agricultural site there was a question
from a member yesterday at the site
visits and I can confirm that the
existing agricultural land is grade
three
there's a view of the existing field
Gate entrance on North Road
mature Hedges either side and this is
looking South along the frontage down
towards
the main built up form of Brad Worthy
similarly looking South towards the
existing development in Bradbury you'll
see that there's development taking
place on the opposite side of the road
there
and then looking North along the
frontage of the site which is on the
left hand side of the picture
um out of Brad worthy looking towards
the dwellings at honokots to the north
there
so as I previously stated this is an
outline application so we haven't got
details of the proposed development the
applicant did provide an indicative site
plan so just to demonstrate that they
could provide up to 22 dwellings on the
site but but this is only for for
information and illustrative purposes at
this stage
we do however have the opportunity to
consider the details for the access as
part of this application so the proposal
is to relocate the Hedge Banks and set
them back at the frontage of the site to
create the relevant visibility splay the
access to be fairly Central in sight and
also for the relocation of 30 mile an
hour Zone further north
an application plan just to show what
the existing habitats on the site are as
we've got hedge Banks to the northern
Southern and Eastern boundaries the
western boundary is not marked on the
site physically as existing and the
development would require the removal of
two of the mature trees to the frontage
again this is a million indicative and
illustrative plan at this stage but just
indicates that additional habitat could
be provided in accordance with council's
biodiversity policies along with the
Quantum of development that's being
sought
and again just a proposed
illustrative drainage strategy of how
that both are foul and surface water
drainage could be dealt with within the
site
so to move on to the planning
considerations
and the principle is the key factor here
as is highlighted in the office's report
there's an addendum set out on pages
21-22 of your agendas
the application was previously commit
considered by the plans committee back
in 2021 and there was a resolution to
Grant the application subject to a
section 106 agreement
and that was based on the policy context
in place at the time and the council's
lack of a five-year housing land Supply
there has been no sign section 106
agreement completed prior to the council
issuing
The Five-Year housing land Supply
statement on the 28th of April
so therefore the applications come back
to the plans committee to be
reconsidered in light of this changed
policy context so I just point members
to um
page 21 of the agenda where it sets out
that towards the bottom that the
application site is located outside of
the settlement boundary and your
officers would consider it therefore to
be contrary to the provisions of policy
st07
particularly section four
and also takes account of the spatial
strategy for Brad Worthy
which makes clear that development how
the how development should continue
within the within the settlement but the
important point being the supporting
text does indicate that there is a clear
development boundary outside of which
the principle of residential development
would only be supported on an
exceptional basis
so in light of this and the council's
established five-year housing land
Supply position the application is now
considered to be contrary to these
policies as set out in the reason for
refusal which is on page 22 the members
okay thank you
I mean officer
right I know go to the public speaking
list we have a letter to be read out
from Brad worthy Parish Council which
Helen will read out
you will have already read in the
committee report that bradwoody Parish
Council strongly opposed the original
application the parish council is
relieved to read that the planning
officer is now recommending refusal of
this application and we would ask that
you please agree to refuse the
application as per your officer's advice
breadworthy Parish Council remains very
strongly opposed to this application for
all the reasons cited in its original
response the parish council would like
to stress again that the site you are
considering today is outside the
development boundary there isn't there
is no housing survey evidence that these
extra 22 houses are needed the Strategic
site
brdo2 has recognized and agreed
for housing within the north Devon and
Torres local plan for 15 houses that
have yet to be developed within the
development boundary
there is a huge amount of development
currently taking place in the village
planning permission has already been
granted for approximately 80 houses
within the immediate Village most of
which are now under construction
bradworthy Primary Academy is
oversubscribed although they are
building a substantial extension to the
school this is to accommodate pupils
already at the Academy not to expand
numbers the doctor's surgery remains
very very oversubscribed by patients
our infrastructure is unable to cope
apparently Southwest water is concerned
that the breadworthy sewage treatment
capacity is becoming overwhelmed roads
into bradworthy are just not suitable
for the additional vehicle movements
which would be generated by this
development pedestrians are at risk
especially children going to and from
school most of North Road has no
Pavements which makes this an even more
dangerous road traffic often travels
along this road at speeds far in excess
of the 30 mile an hour limit bradfordy
Parish Council would respectfully ask
that its concerns are taken into
consideration
speaker is Stephen Bainbridge speaking
in support of the application if you'd
like to come to the microphone you have
three minutes
thank you chair and the thank you
members for letting me speak today my
thanks also to members who resolve to
approve the application last time it was
here
um
sorry that it's come back um you know
we've done our absolute best to move the
section 106 forwards we did delay that
initially to try and get a developer on
board so that the section 106 was signed
up to the developer who would actually
be delivering the site in the hope that
we would be able to deliver the site far
more quickly in the long run we are in a
position now where should you resolve to
approve the application again we can
move forward finalize the 106
immediately and and move move this case
forward thank you also to the case
officer for her detailed report and for
the presentation there
as the officer's report shows there's no
technical objections whatsoever to this
application
and that is in line with the previous
resolution of of this committee the only
reason this application is being brought
back is due to the council's recent
five-year housing land Supply position
of 5.9 years
0.9 years more than the minimum required
this position is yet to be tested
externally but we're aware there are a
number of appeals in the system which
will seek to do so often this does
result in that number falling
we don't know to what extent that will
be
but this application for 22 dwellings if
approved today can help bolster that the
council's five-year housing land Supply
we note in the five-year housing land
Supply report that this application is
calculated as delivering towards the
housing Supply in the six to ten year
period which means in less than one year
the council will be reliant on these 22
dwellings to bolster its five-year
housing land Supply position
members this scheme as I said is only
unacceptable because it is on the wrong
line of an a wrong side of an arbitrary
line that's drawn around the settlement
and as mentioned previously there are
reasons that members can choose still to
approve this application and we believe
that those reasons are met we have
progressed so far with this application
that it is a pre-packaged application
ready to go and be delivered there's
been a significant amount of work done
by your members your planning officers
your consultation and your legal team as
well as a significant amount of
investment by the applicant which we
hope will not be in vain
members we hope that you will be able to
approve this application and that will
be able to deliver 22 dwellings
immediately adjacent to the village in a
sustainable location and that the
affordable housing for local people will
be delivered we respectfully request you
approve the application thank you
yeah thank you um well it's fascinating
this has come back I do know from the
last speaker that it was only brought
back due to the change in the five-year
land Supply
I would point out it was only passed due
to the five-year land Supply we were
over a barrel and we had to pass it
going back to the
um the fact that you know it's all oven
ready and everything
um this is outside the development
boundary and I take on board what
brandworthy parish council said about
this site and this was argued the last
time it came up but as I say we were
completely hamstrung over what we could
do about this and quite frankly I don't
think it should go ahead I I can't
remember how I voted last time I
probably voted for it because we had to
but now we do have that choice and I
would recommend that it isn't passed and
I will propose that
yes I was surprised to see it come back
but obviously for the reasons that in
the in the report
and listening to the brabworthy
submissions that was read out from the
planning manager and I noticed in our
report
the huge amount of unbuilt houses that
have been permitted already in bradburg
were they way above a what's in the
local plan for bradworth is a
development and as councilor Christie
said we were
we were stuck really last time it came
forward because we hadn't got this
five-year housing land Supply so I'm
happy to accept and cancel Christie's
proposal to refuse
I think not any other speakers is cancer
Pennington
thank you chair I just wanted to ask a
question in the light of the fact that
the previous application
appears to have died
um why is it not being given a new
number and why are we making a legal
judgment that the 106 judgment has
agreement has failed
so therefore
this should be seen then as a new
application in its own right
and we judge it on that and then I would
agree with the two previous speakers
that we you know on grounds to refuse it
given the amount of building up probably
but I'm slightly concerned that we're
still using the yield number and it sets
a precedent because we have applications
that have been passed previously that
are now going to fall and I suspect that
there may be others that may come
through the pipeline now we've got to
take this on its own Merit but the key
question here from my point of view this
is a new application effectively and it
should be seen in that light can you
explain to me why it's being brought
back under the old number
yeah thank you councilor Pennington so
it it's it's not treated as a new
application it's it's the same
application the same proposal under the
same reference number yes it has come
before committee once before where there
was a resolution to Grant Subject to a
section 106. now that as as the officer
Jose explained that section 106 has
never been completed we cannot issue a
decision until such time as the section
106 is completed the policy context at
the point of decision is is the point
when a decision is actually issued so
given the change in policy context
whilst this application is still being
detectically determined because a
decision hasn't been issued yet means
that it has to come back before
committee it's not a new application it
is the same application
however there has been a change in
context
so the decision has to be has to now be
re-looked at by Committee in light of
that changing context which is which is
all down to the five year land Supply
position so so it is the same
application councilor Pennington
you wish to come back
so given that's a situation that is
going to come back should
the applicant produce a one or six
agreement with then that allow the
previous application to stand that's my
concern we're going to get into a middle
here
so what I'm saying is legally it's a
dead application surely before we should
look at this application I'm just trying
to cover our back from a not a planning
point of view we're making legal
decisions here now not planning
decisions which I think is beyond the
remit of our committee actually
it is still a planning decision that
you're making the section 106 is a key
component of that decision-making
process so the development is off a
scale that it generates the need for
infrastructure section 106 monies and
on-site Provisions the only way to
secure that is through a section 106.
um from a legal decision-making point of
view
um the that section 106 could you know
there is still time for that to be
completed as the applicant as the agent
has said however the the councils your
officer's position is that even where
the signs section 106 The Proposal is
now not acceptable because of a change
in polity context so yes there has been
a positive resolution by committee
however the application has never been
determined formally because the decision
has not been issued it's the same
application as for applications that
have been determined already
and a section 106 signed in advance of
the April publication of the position
statement though those decisions aren't
affected because legally they are
determined and there is a decision out
there and there are there aren't very
many applications at all that are in
this this position of having to come
back before you okay
not unless counselor pendulum wants any
clarification
any further comments yes track it
I'm conflicted by this one
um
I see the response from South West
Waters saying they can supply
well they can provide clean potable
water services that's a new expression
for me but um I take there's not a
problem here do we happen to know if
there's a community speed watch working
in Brad Worthy
we don't I I don't know off the top of
my head I'm afraid I'd like to know the
fears about speeding are Justified
um you know normally you would
here there was a parish that was doing
something about the problem
um on the other side of the thing I'm
section 106. this is what the Crux of
the matter is and I see on page 29 We
have basically
the draft
provisions of a section 106.
and I can't understand why it wasn't
signed
to expedite this matter before the 28th
of April
maybe head of legal could shed some
light on why this could not have been
done
you know why are we in this position
I I don't know councilor Hackett I
haven't been involved in in the 106. uh
Helen Maine have a bit more information
on that I I think that Laura's case
officer is probably best place to answer
about the series of events that led up
to the end of April
I think as the agent
um outlined in in his three minutes
um there's been some discussion about
whether a developer would take on the
sites and so whether they were going to
be a signatory to the 106 which delayed
it for some time
um and and I believe other factors in
terms of the sale of the site but
nothing that from our point of view if
you like that that necessarily
slowed it down and we you know our
solicitors have done what they can to um
to move it forward as fast as possible
the agent couldn't have signed the 106.
to have it
that's a question for him I'm afraid I
don't know when I'm not in Liberty to
ask that question
[Music]
is
that question but
you know we have a
we have a site that it is near
you know
I'm absolutely conflicted by this one as
I said because yes it is outside the
development line but the site
is pretty near
good to go and you have all done a lot
of work on it
yeah okay
I shall make a decision later yes
foreign
I don't want to labor this one because
it's been proposed and secondly to
refuse it but speaking in general during
the
period when we didn't have the five-year
housing land Supply lots of speculative
developments were put forward in the
district we managed to back battle one
off eventually at Windmill Lane which
was speculative although when it was
presented and many of them were
presented and they say oh we're ready to
go we've got to develop blah blah it's
obviously this site was in my view
speculative there was no developer lined
up to go with it and the Agents
obviously been struggling to find
somebody
and say well I'll accept that bit of 106
but I won't accept that bit so it'll go
to another developer oh I'm happy with
that but I don't know and that's why I
think it's not happening it hasn't been
signed and now it's a good time and it's
the same application which I'm pretty
sure we would have refused before if we
hadn't got this balance tilted balance
we had to do so yeah thank you any
further comments
discussion
um unfortunately councilor Smith can't
participate in the vote because he
wasn't here at the beginning of the
presentation so it has been proposed by
a councilor Christie executive by
accounts the leather that the
applications refuse so we will now go to
the recorded vote
thank you chair councilor Christie
councilor Gibson
councilor Hackett
councilor Haynes
councilor leather
councilor lock for
councilor Pennington for
councilor Wheatley
oh that's seven four chair one against
and one abstention so that application
is refused
moving on to Item B application
it's on pages
52-59 of your agenda
are there any decorations
I would declare an interest because I
haven't speaking in support as well
remember
and I will leave the committee format
yes good morning councils I'm Vice chair
Peter Haynes of the planning committee
um
continue with this application office
the officer will now give a report
please is that right
we've had any Declarations of Interest
sorry we've just had that haven't we yes
councilors are many Declarations of
interest on this application
yeah that's what I thought right that's
why it's going on to the officer will
now give a report I hope
uh thank you Vice chair my name's Ryan
steppel and I'm the case officer for
this application one oblique zero three
four nine twenty twenty two UT
oh sorry
um the application is for an outline
application with all matters reserved
for one local needs dwelling in um in
so for your slide here you've got the
location plan
um just a quick verbal update before
before I proceed on
um the delegates from the committee
report refers to the previous committee
date because the application did did go
to Committee in on the 6th of October
however the report refers to the 9th of
September
and please proceed
we should have some aerial images here
but we're just having a little bit of a
lag so as you can see the site is
outlined in red there it's approximately
0.7 miles
um to the east of Dalton
located off the b3217 road
and if we just go to the next slide
Helen
and this this slide just indicates the
sort of rural context in the sides and
it's sort of surrounding context and so
for you there you have a resident a
residential dwelling located immediately
to the South and then some agricultural
buildings immediately to the sort of
Northeast there and then obviously that
hatched areas that the site
worth noting at this point that there
was a planning permission approved in
2020 which sought to change the use of
land and erect a forestry building which
has now been implemented and along with
that permission sought to create a new
access which was deemed acceptable by
highways and was therefore approved
foreign
these are the images of
um these are the images so we've got on
on the top left you've got the that
forestry building that I discussed
previously as well as the access on that
top right image and
um that image to the South is where the
proposed dwelling would be located
um in place of that sort of dilapidated
bomb
and here we have a sort of view from
that that access which was um
implemented and so the image on the left
is a view East towards sort of the
beacon bus and coach and the sort of a
road
um and then on on the right reasonably
good visibility as we can see there
and these are some images showing the
surrounding sort of rural context in
terms of the highways I think
particularly important to note the sort
of limited footpath provision and um not
lit and I just think I wanted to make
that clear within this presentation
and here we all move on to the drawing
so we have a site plan here and then I
think a more zoomed in version of the
Cyclone if we go to the next slide
so as we can see that's where the
proposed dwelling is located
the black dotted line indicates that
dilapidated bond that we saw as well as
the sort of um drainage and turning
turning areas and and the access which
was has been implemented
um so
these are the main planning
considerations I think the principal
development
um is particularly key here
um obviously your officer report
suggests that
that the application should be refused
due to being in the countryside outside
of development boundary and contrary to
policy st07
I think in terms of the
um the previous resolution to Grant the
application back in October I think it's
quite clear to say that the policy
context is is different to them the
application was previously considered
against a tilted balance which looked to
the pros and the positive and negative
effects of the dwelling of the dwelling
um it was picked up in site visits about
whether there would be any sort of
economic justification or rural worker
justification put forward the planning
statements submitted with the
application confirms that this is not
the case and it should be purely
considered against whether it's a local
needs dwelling in the countryside we're
flagging that as it does in the officer
report that and the council has a policy
in relation to rural workers dwellings
in terms of local needs to adding some
local occupancy dwellings but this does
not apply as the site is not within the
rural assessment and it's clearly in the
countryside
um in terms of the character and
appearance and Immunity and that was
considered last time and the prose was
not substantively different in terms of
those aspects
um like in the previous committee we
considered the highways aspects in terms
of The Limited
Footwear provision
um
and we had the other considerations
which should drainage ecology and
conclusion thank you for your time
thank you very much
um we have two public speakers today one
Harrison Jennings in support and to the
ward councilor Rosemary Locke in support
so when I asked Harrison Jennings to
come forward please
good morning sir you have three minutes
to make your cake
firstly I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank you all for your
time patience today as we discuss the
development of Half Penny yard
some of you may remember me from last
September but for those who don't I
would like to begin by introducing
myself
hello everyone my name is Harrison I'm
24 years old I live in Dalton a village
in which I've lived and loved my whole
life I attended Dalton Primary School
alongside both my brother and sister and
I've lived in the same family home
throughout my life
I've always worked locally to Dalton
starting at Beacon garage where my
parents work only a mile outside the
village therefore being a substantial
reason as to why Dalton is a big part of
me and a place I want in my future
I now run my own firewood and taxi
business employing 21 local people
showing an employment growth of 16 from
last September
during the past couple years I've been
selling firewood to the local community
a business in which has grown
substantially and predicted to expand
greatly due to the current price of
price increase of electric and heating
oil
I can now say this winter season the
sales and fire would increase by 110
showing a clear demand for my service in
the area
this business is located at the plotted
land of which I own a half penny yard
through running the business at Half
Penny yard it has given me the
opportunity to expand and further my
plans with firewood alongside these
plans comes moving out to the family
home a decision which is currently being
held back due to a lack of availability
and affordable housing within the local
area
a barrier which has increased greatly
over the years for first-time buyers
therefore I'm hoping to build upon the
land a half penny yard so I'm able to
settle and start my own family with my
partner whom I've been with for seven
years my partner has grown up locally
and is currently undergoing teacher
training within the local primary school
I'd love for my family my future family
to be able to grow up in the same
Village and surrounding local
communities me
I'm not looking to build in the middle
of nowhere there are other dwellings
within the vicinity some of which have
written in support of my application
I feel what I'm trying to achieve is
adding to the existing Hamlet of
properties in the area I've already
enhanced the area since purchasing the
property by removing a derelict shed and
replacing it with a purpose-built
building for my business I've also
created a new entrance to the property
which has vastly improved the visibility
for me and those traveling the road both
of which went through the planning
process last year
there's currently a double Barn in the
corner of the site which is on view from
the road I already have Water and
Electric on-site so the impact the
surroundings would be minimal if I'm
successful with this application this
bomb would be replaced to create my
family home which will further enhance
the area
with the potential this yard with the
potential of this yard being my future
family home creating a safe environment
within the supportive Community is
extremely important to me within recent
years I've played and sponsored the
local football team and often watch
their matches as well as this over the
past three years I've also volunteered
as the local snow Warden a role in which
I hope to carry on for many more years
and one that has proven necessary since
being here last September and you wind
up soon please sir yeah okay I truly
approve this opportunity and hope you
can be sympathetic to my needs and
support me and my future plans as you
did before thank you for listening
thanks very much thank you
uh now called Ward councilor Rosemary
lock to speak and support
our speaker's World member in support of
this application you would have seen
from the zoom site visits yesterday
although as per our local plan and the
term in the open Countryside you would
have seen that within the cartilage
there is a new agricultural shed
for the applicant forestry business and
one of the benefits of this application
was that it made the access and egress
to the site acceptable in Highway terms
and indeed improve visibility on this
section of the road for all Road users
immediately to the East and Northeast
there are two dwellings and farm
buildings
the site is located 0.7 miles in the
center of Dalton Dalton is a vibrant
Village we have a church chapel School
vibrant Village Hall a butcher's shop an
electric saw a general store with post
office two public houses a football team
a large well-equipped children's play
area and a free Village car park
the office of states and his report as a
designated local Center Dalton contains
the services necessary to support a
residential use
page 57 goes on to say that the site is
located on a narrow Rural Road without
street light in all footpaths in fact
the road into Dalton is on two vehicle
width and even as a white line down the
center for most of the length of it
and when you enter the village there are
street lights and some Pavements we have
a good bus service we are on the main 5B
route and have a regular service which
All Buses pass the site and there is a
bus stop at Dalton Beacon and one in the
village
we talk a lot about and maintaining the
vibrancy of town centers this statement
also applies to many of our villages we
must encourage the younger members of
our community who have been born and
brought up in such villages to remain to
ensure the future of our Village Schools
and businesses on Rightmove at Dalton at
the moment there are three properties
priced over 550 000 five at four hundred
to four hundred and fifty thousand and
five are over three hundred thousand all
these are out of the range of the
applicant to remain in the village where
he grew up and has his business building
a modest home on the land that he owns
in conjunction with his twin brother is
the only option open to him
highways have no objections the
Environmental Protection Officer has no
objections subject to a construction
maintenance condition and that the
dwelling design centering to the
neighboring forestry business
Dalton Parish Council support provided
that it remains a local news Dwayne
there are no objections there are four
letters of support on the plan and
portal one of which is from the
residents of the large white dwelling
immediately opposite the application
site which you would have noticed on the
zoom site visits
the application Accords with policies
sto1 dm01 dm24
st-10 dm05 and dm06 and using the till
to balance the argument the benefits
greatly outweigh any identified arm in
fact the opposite in his report on page
56 States in 3A that it would not
significantly harm the amenities of any
neighboring properties
the Environmental Protection Officer is
satisfied with the FDA assessment and
the percolation tests
and you the commit I ask you the
committee to support this application
subject to the two conditions that it
Remains the local needs when in and it
and Sydney to the forestry business so I
hope you will support this application
thank you
thank you right now open up a discussion
just to clarify we're talking in a
context of
Again The Five-Year fulfilling of
five-year housing Supply and so we're
into Now sort of referring to policy
considerations rather than yeah so
anyone want to speak first councilor
Christie
thank you um yeah can I just make one
point it says in our report on page 52
at the top following a resolution to
approve from the plans Committee in the
9th of September 2022 I've actually been
back to look at that that meeting was
postponed uh the actual decision was
taken the next month uh just
planning off yeah sorry I I you might
not have caught that early on I did um
sort of verbal update I'm sorry for that
um no I looked I checked back what
happened the last time and it says it
was proposed by councilor leather
secondary by councilor Christie the
application be approved
um and there were nine conditions put on
it the officers were suggesting and I've
got no problem with this because this is
a it's a rural industry I can see that
very clearly and I think the applicant
when he appeared last time made a very
good case for this I know we have to be
very careful about these ones but
clearly you know this is a business as
far as Sheen it's it needs to be in the
countryside and I I would actually
propose I don't know if councilor
leather would like to Second it and this
time or whether you would like to
propose it and I'll second it but it's
up to you
that's a
um sorry
okay
there we go
um I was going to support this
um you know what a pillar of the
community young ladder 24
born grown up in the community
and this represents shall we say in all
organic development of the settlement of
Dalton you know I live in a village
location I'm aware that
we don't always need Pavement in our
rural communities this is a safe road to
walk along you know
most nights I go around a three mile
circuit to Black Torrington
and back to seat wash you know you get
used to it
the lack of street lights isn't a
problem you know and
here he is a young lad who's got a taxi
business he's dealing in firewood for
the local community his partner is a
teacher in training I wish we had more
lads like this in our communities who
want to sort of build
and strengthen
you know sponsor the local football team
what more can you ask but
head must rule heart
we have policies that support str1 dm05
dm06 it's all there so
I'm right behind this
and keep the two conditions on as the
speaker said the war counselor yeah I
think we've got to go with it councilor
leather thank you
thank you Vice chair uh yeah
I'd love I'd like to add to this because
it as councilor Christie said and of
course with new members on this
committee now it was thoroughly
discussed when it came up before it's
only come back now because of this
technicality that this certificate
wasn't served on the twin brother as
well
um
it would be absolute crying shame if we
reverse what we really considered in
depth when it came up in October
so I am happy to Second it councilor
Christie's proposal I would like to add
the mppf 84 and 85 to this as well
because it does stay here
the development at 84 B the development
and diversification of agricultural and
other land-based rural businesses they
spoke not supporting a prosperous and
Rural economy and at 85 it speaks of
planning policies and decisions should
recognize that sites to meet local
business and Community needs in rural
areas may have to be found adjacent to
or Beyond existing settlements and in
locations that are not well served by
public transport
and in these circumstances it'll be
important to ensure the development is
sensitive to its surroundings which
there surely is and it's a local needs
dwelling so I really am very happy to
Second this chair thank you may I just
ask the officer what situation is about
the taxi business with that
was that inclusion no that that part is
not included within this application and
um yeah it's not subject to this plan
application
um although it might well have to be
exhausted through a future application
if the indeed necessary so confined to
the existing
business you know
otherwise we've got a proposed on a
secondary
if I could just come in
um I know cancer Christie you referred
to the previous conditions that were
agreed as per the minutes of the sixth
of October I think it was
um there were conditions recommended
covering the standard outline and
Reserve matters sort of time condition
and requirement for submission of
Reserve matters standard plans condition
restriction on construction hours
full contamination condition
felt a condition requiring details of
foul drainage
um condition requiring that access
parking and maneuvering will be provided
on site prior to occupation
um that the development be carried out
in accordance with the recommendations
of the ecology report and that permitted
development rights be removed so just
checking councilor Christopher you're
happy that the the recommendation
includes
they are they are but
yes I was just going to come on to that
so the advice given to the committee
back in October well that that's best
done via a unilateral undertaking or
section 106 agreement
um so your officer's recommendation
would be that there is an Associated
legal agreement that restricts the
dwelling to the local needs occupancy
criteria and also that it's tied to the
timber business that's on site so just
checking that councilor Christie's happy
that that forms part of his
recommendation
put my microphone on this time yes I am
happy with it
yeah I'm glad you raised that Council
Christie because sorry Council
just to clarify with the planning
manager then on that
if it's tied to the business because the
business wasn't included within the red
line
it's just a local needs dwelling that
we're looking at
surely if the business went this would
still be a local needs dwelling without
with or without the business it's a
local news dwelling yeah if I could just
clarify that the reason for tying it to
the business is down to the comments of
the Environmental Protection Officer
because there would if somebody not
connected to the business lived in the
dwelling there would be amenity harm and
so it doesn't mean that if the business
ceased that the local needs dwelling
with sea so the local needs dwelling is
there but it's almost the other way
around Council leather that the business
can't operate other than in in
conjunction with whoever's living in the
toiling that makes sense it's tying
those uses together
okay thanks very much so we've come to a
decision now so on a recorded vote thank
you
thank you councilor Christie four
councilor Gibson
councilor Hackett
henceler Haynes for
councilor leather or counselor lock old
sorry
counselor Pennington four councilor
Smith
counselor Wheatley four
that's unanimous chair
oh
thank you
all right our next application is
application once wrote 0087 boarding
Cattery chills where the pages 60 to 69
of your agenda are there any decorations
of Interest
no I now ask the officer to give the
report then thank you
thank you chair and good morning uh
members and members of the public my
name is James Jackson I'm a principal
planning officer at turret District
Council and uh as the chair said I'm
here to present application 7 item 7c of
your agenda which is one double eight
seven twenty twenty three ful and
proposal is the erection of a boarding
Cattery to include a kitchen and office
with 15 units and this is a site in
chillsworthy which is known as West
Villa chillsworthy in holsworthy
uh next slide please
the left hand side slide there shows the
site location edged in red
uh it's um a small part of a wider site
that's owned by the applicants which is
edged in blue which essentially
comprises three uh paddocks there's an
existing dog grooming and breeding
business at the site and um committee
members that have previously sat on
plans committee may also recall that
they've um that we've granted planning
permission for a dog kennels and dog
exercise area and a pet crematorium and
also the retention of a mobile home on
the site
um
the site is bounded by the
um public Highway on the on the western
edge there and the existing access there
as well we've also got a third party
dwelling on the opposite side of the
opposite side of the public highway
there and then to the south of the site
on the bottom of that blue line is the
applicants dwelling in Annex and some
outbuildings as well and then further
across to the South East we've got a
number of third-party dwellings
including two recently constructed
dwellings that aren't shown on that
particular plan
and then further over to the east we
have
um further existing residential
development including some dwellings
that have been recently constructed at
kernel house comprising five detached
dwellings and there's also a planning
permission there at stamp permission for
a further three dwellings
uh the the main bulk of main body of the
the village is over to the to the East
and the southeast and then just on the
right hand side I thought would be
useful for members to see the
relationship of the site to um to the
development boundary for the Village
um there you can see the site with the
red star and uh the development boundary
um obviously outlined in black
um it's just worth noting that proximity
really
um and obviously the the pink shaded
area is a is the allocation within
holsworthy which is allocated I believe
for six houses there's no ACC stamp
permission on on that currently uh next
slide please
this on the right hand either left hand
side sorry just shows an aerial image of
that from Google again with the red star
um marks the uh the site and here we can
see to the South those two dwellings
that I mentioned that weren't shown on
the previous plan and the recently
constructed you can see those to the
south of the site there and again
further obviously East you can see the
development site at kerno house which is
the development of five dwellings and
then further to the north uh that kind
of excavated area you can is where
there's an extant permission for three
further dwellings and then we have over
on the right hand side just an aerial
image again the star uh to note to the
site and that just shows the
relationship of the site to The Wider
area in holesworthy
next slide please
this is just the existing site plan
which which effectively is the same as
the site location plan but without the
red line on it again showing the um the
the existing layout
next slide please
and then this is the proposed site plan
so um on the left hand side is is the
sort of wider image and that's what it
might be useful to just show you an
enlarged image of that showing the
Cuttery just on the right hand side so
we can see that the category building
would be located within close proximity
to the existing access to the site and
includes a car parking area there which
again would be next to the access and
then we've got the Cattery building
there itself which is a a rectangular
building with a wildflower area sewn in
front of that and then hedge Banks
constructed and planted out on the East
and western and southern side of the
Cattery to the immediate north of the
Cattery is an existing mature Hedgerow
that would be retained as part of as
part of the um proposal and then that
blue line on the right hand side image
is just the soak away that we deal with
surface water runoff associated with the
building
next slide please
this is the proposed elevations and
floor plans it's a building of almost 30
meters long and 4.3 meters wide and 2.2
meters high its highest point it
comprises as shown on the floor plan at
the bottom of the slide 15
different pens for for the Cattery and
each of those has a maximum occupancy of
two cats but that would be on the basis
that those cats are from the same
household and get on well so there is a
potential maximum occupancy of the of
the kennel of the boarding category of
30 cats to the right hand side there's a
small kitchen shown there on the floor
plan and that's a requirement of the
license the facility would be licensed
by torrage District Council and on the
left hand side a small office building
there as well the building will be
constructed largely of upvc Framing and
panels and glazing as well next slide
please
this is just shows the um Cutlery
building in the context of the Hedge
banks that you could have seen that you
saw on the proposed site plan so
um we've obviously just got elevations
there that show that the majority of the
building would be hidden from view by
those hedge banks on the right hand side
is the specification of the Hedge bank
which obviously is fairly fairly
substantial and excite please
and just some photographs here on the
left hand side is looking back towards
the site I'm stood in the southern part
of that Paddock looking back towards the
Northwest the existing access is over on
the left hand side there and on the
right hand side image is a closer shot
basically you can see the access there
on the left hand side and that existing
Gateway which is in the foreground would
be used to access the category building
from the car parking area which is also
shown in the distance there on that
photograph
next slide please
the left hand shot is looking at the
site looking west across the site and
again in the distance there you can see
the existing access and car parking area
and the right hand shot is taken from
the public Highway looking into the site
obviously you've got the entrance doors
there and a boundary fence and then the
the site Beyond next slide please
the left hand is the proposed parking
area and the right hand is the existing
Gateway that would be used to access the
category and then over in that far
corner of that slide is where committee
previously have granted plan permission
for the kennels building
next slide please
the left hand side is stood in the
northern part of that Paddock looking
South and so there on the right hand
side of that shot we have the applicants
dwelling in Annex on and then further to
the center there's the mobile home that
was granted planning permission by
committee and a stand of large mature
trees on the opposite side of those
trees is the two recently constructed
dwellings and then further over to the
left is
um uh other third-party dwellings as
well
and on the right hand side is a shot of
the pet crematorium also permitted by um
by plans committee previously just by
coincidence when I made my site visit
that had recently been delivered to site
and as you can see it's obviously sat on
a concrete plinth and is housed within a
shipping container as was permitted and
members may also recall that we
um some Landscaping was permitted as
well and that will obviously be
following due course
next slide please
so the following considerations there
are relevant to the proposed development
today for members to consider in terms
of the principle of development that is
established by policy dm14 of the local
plan which supports small-scale Economic
Development where on sites where they
are well related to existing settlements
and from your officer's perspective that
that this proposal obviously meets those
criteria due to its proximity to the
existing Village of toolsworthy the
character and appearance is considered
acceptable by virtue of
um the Hedge Banks largely that would
surround the um the Cattery and and um
mitigate most of the the visual impact
there and highways terms the highways uh
Authority is referred to its standing
advice document only and so it doesn't
raise any objection
um and from your officer's perspective
the uh visibility of the access is
acceptable and the surrounding Highway
Network can accommodate the level of
traffic generated by by the development
residential amenity as always is is key
there are a number of third-party
dwellings within the um within the area
you'll have seen in your offices report
the comments from the Environmental
Protection Officer to comment that he
has no concerns about this proposal
given that it wouldn't be noise
generating particularly or or
particularly odorous and importantly
obviously committee have previously
granted kennels on this business on on
this site I know there's some comments
from a neighbor and also from the Paris
Council raising concerns about
the possibility around a Cattery and a
dog kennels on the same site and that's
been specifically discussed with the
Environmental Protection Officer and
you'll see in his comments that he notes
that either on its own or cumulatively
he would have no concerns about this
um that's largely because the the two
buildings
um this building and also the kennels
that was previously permitted the
purpose-built facilities by a company in
Malvern called pedigree pens
and also the Hedge banks will limit the
the visibility between those two
facilities and therefore reduce the
visual uh the sort of stimulus that
would be apparent there for the animals
on the site
in terms of biodiversity the proposed
hedge Banks would deliver biodiversity
enhancement at site and surface water
drainage is is adequately dealt with by
The Soca so
um taking all that account it's your
officer's view that the proposal would
be Accord with the development plan and
accordingly it's recommended that um
that the application be approved subject
to the conditions in your agenda thank
you chair
thank you James on our turn to the
public speakers it's the first
registered speaker is Mr Richard Ainsley
who's speaking against the application
if you'd like to come to the front
foreign
button yep
and you have three minutes there thank
you
good morning it is still morning
my name is Richard Ainsley and my wife
and I have lived and paid rates at
Chills already for 27 years we live over
the fence from these proposed
developments my objection is the obvious
over development involved
chillsworth is a quiet residential
Village there are no shops or pubs save
a village hall it's by no means a
commercial or Industrial Place
the applicant's family arrival was
heralded by appearances of two signs
when they moved in loose dogs and CCTV
in operation both inappropriate to a
local to the locale they soon started
breeding dogs then they applied to build
two houses on a vegetable patch just a
few meters from our house
this was widely opposed and more than a
little controversial after many
iterations and resubmissions it was
approved to General astonishment during
this time a large static caravan
appeared for which there was no planning
permission I understand this was used in
the dog breeding business
the two houses were built in the absence
of an agreed local plan over 15 months
seven days a week out of agreed hours
including bank holidays and Sundays it
was sheer hell for my wife and me
next they applied for and were refused
permission for an eight-unit dog kennels
plus office plus grooming salon
on the basis of that refusal the two
houses were sold
kennel's proposal was resubmitted and to
wide incredulity it was approved
they then applied to build of all things
like pet crematorium
that was approved despite its patent
absurdity
before the ink was dried on those two
they are now seeking to build this
boarding Cattery with 15 units a kitchen
and an office this all adds up to as
clear a case of over development as you
will see
I see that and note that the delegated
report makes no mention of the two
houses it was indeed this family that
sought and received permission
leaving out the largest most impactful
project here is a noteworthy oversight
to put it very mildly
mixing cats and dogs on the same site as
a Crematory Miss Shirley a recipe for
unpleasantness
the presence of cats is the surest way
to cause The Barking we were assured
would not damage our immunity
such Assurance is are worthless in the
case of the houses it was stipulated
that work should not begin until August
after bird nesting season in fact the
heavy equipment arrived in June tore up
all the trees and bushes and dug down to
a depth of five feet leaving nothing
whatsoever alive
so much for these assurances
holdsworthy Hamlet's Parish Council
voted unanimously to oppose this project
the concerns of all those affected have
been utterly disregarded brushed aside
as if they did not matter
that's not how it's meant to work in a
democracy I quote the PC's the parish
council please you've had three minutes
counselors see little point in
responding and are disheartened that
their comments are not taken into
account by towards District Council
which repeatedly ignores the local
Council advice
that's them saying this is sad surely
enough is enough enough damage enough
exploitation enough Democratic deficit
please see that some sense of proportion
prevails by refusing this application
thank you for your time thank you
and that reason speaker is that Mr Ben
Harris speaking in support of the
application
again you have three minutes thank you
have you put the green light on yeah
it's on yeah okay
okay so uh thank you anyway
um so the Cattery would be a perfect
addition to the kennels business
um because many people have got dogs
who've got cats as well and it could be
inconvenient for them to go to two
separate facilities
um
it shouldn't have any impact on the
local area because it won't be seen from
outside of the property the gates are
closed most of the time so that'd be the
only place you could see through into
the actual property itself
and as the Environmental Protection
Officer said that cats don't really make
any noise and they don't really smell so
they shouldn't really cause any
disruption to the neighborhood amenity
and once we are fully open we will be
offering local jobs for people and
that's it thank you
and that was right as a speaker is the
world member councilor hepple and the
statement is to be read out by the
planning manager
I called this planning application as
Ward member for and on behalf of
holdsworthy Hamlet's Parish Council and
concerned local chills with the
residents unfortunately I am currently
out of the country and I am therefore
unable to address the members of the
plans Committee in person and would ask
if this brief submission could be read
out by the chair in my absence
1. principle of development the
fundamental question here is as with the
last four applications regarding West
Villa
is West Villa really and practically in
a Countryside location or is it now
integrally part of a village location my
view is as it was with regard to the
last three applications here that West
Villa is now linked directly to and
forms the western boundary of the built
environment that is the rural Village of
chillsworthy primarily because of the
recently consented residential
developments at an adjacent to the
application site
councilor heple then goes on to
reference some applications so I'll just
read out the reference numbers one zero
six eight zero 2018 and one one one
seven for 2019 out which relates to two
dwellings on land adjacent to west villa
application one forward slash zero eight
eight eight eight forward slash 2018
forward slash out six dwellings on land
between Braeside and West Park
application one forward slash zero four
five three of 2017 out five dwellings on
land adjacent to Colonel house and
finally application one forward slash
zero three seven two
twenty twenty out three dwellings also
consented on land adjacent to kerno
house
it is noted by committee members that
the plan that is shown on the front
piece of the officer's report as it
appears on the planning portal as I
write this submission at 0800 hours
Tuesday the 6th of June omits all of
these both built and consented
residential development that now mean
that in my view West Bella West Villa is
now exorbably part of chillsworthy
Village
as such I submit that the application
can no longer in Practical terms be
deemed to be development in the
countryside moreover the officers report
emits reference in the relevant history
to Applications one forward slash zero
six eight zero of twenty twenty eighteen
out and one forward slash 1174 of 2019
ful which relate to consent granted for
two detached dwelling houses now built
and occupied on land that at that time
formed part of West Villa where the main
thrust of the agent's submission on
behalf of the applicants at that time
being was that the site was a
long-established part of the village
visually and physically and is
surrounded by dwellings on two sides the
site is therefore considered to be
within the village and subject to policy
DVT too
0.2 planning policy
ndtlp policy st07 relates to spatial
development strategy in the countryside
Beyond local centers Villages and Rural
settlements I would argue that the
application site is now part of the
village that is chillswithy and
consequently it is not now Beyond The
Village
polity st11 states that proposals for
economic development would be supported
where they do not conflict with other
local plan policies I would argue that
the proposal here does conflict with
policy sto7 and is therefore contrary to
policies st07 and st11
policy dm14 providing principal support
for small-scale economic development in
the countryside and as stated in my view
the application site is not now properly
within a Countryside location because of
a series of consented and built
residential developments and the
proposal is therefore contrary to policy
dm14
policy dmo1 confirms that development
will be supported where it would not
harm the amenities of neighboring
properties and conversely it is assumed
that development will not be supported
where it would cause harm to the
amenities of neighboring properties
with the now consented commercial dog
kennels located within less than 100
yards of neighboring properties I would
argue that allowing a boarding category
on the same site cannot but result in a
harmful effect on neighboring amenities
the officer's report refers to the TDC
Environmental Protection officer's first
report that concluded cats are not named
for generating significant levels of
noise or odor and in the second report
advises that the proposed development
will not result in a significant adverse
impact either in its own respect or
cumulatively with the above mentioned
businesses dog boarding kennels pet
crematorium at West Villa I have to
disagree with the Environmental
Protection Officer with regard to the
cumulative effect here since as far as I
am aware there is nothing quite like the
proximity of a cat to set off a dog
barking and as with the previous
application for the dog boarding kennels
it must be appreciated and understood
that noise levels monitored from within
one building the dog kennels and within
another building nearby houses will be
fundamentally different to the noise
levels that will be experienced by
residents of those same dwellings trying
to enjoy their Gardens outdoor amenity
space resulting from dogs barking in the
open whilst being delivered collected
exercised consequently I believe that
the application is also contrary to
policy dmo1
on behalf of concerned local nearby
residents I would say that the principal
of the proposed development here
is not acceptable in this Village
location and that the proposed boarding
Cattery located on the same site as a
consented dog boarding kennels and
exercise yard is contrary to North Devon
Storage and local plan policies SDA 7
st11 dm14 and dm01 another wrong does
not make a right
the end of the reticent speakers they
are now throw over the metaphor
discussion who'd like to kick off please
cut the leather
thank you chair could we put the
proposed site plan back up please
because
again members on this committee who who
looked at the previous applications for
the crematorium
pet crematorium and the dog kennels you
will see from where Westville is cited
the field nearest to that neighbor
across the road there is completely void
of any development the dog breeding the
dog kennels which are in that right hand
corner they've got a hedge around that
was part of the conditions
um I don't think there'd be a conflict
between the Cattery and the and the dog
kennels because
I don't think dogs are going to be able
to see any cats when they come out or
attacking for a walk up again they move
that dog walking area up into that top
field but that one field has been left
empty within the blue line there's no
development for this business and it is
a a rural business there's it's been
expanded over time obviously but I
really can't see there's a problem with
having a Cattery on the site
and they have enhanced a biodiversity
The Greenery on that site's been
enhanced over time they seem to me to be
very responsible applicants in my view
from from what we've been told this
morning and what some cancers on this
committee have seen in the past I'm
happy to move approval of it
in the other comments please
it's not so much a comment there's
questions really
um when this came before us we're
talking about eight Kennels
eight dogs
we're now talking about 15 cat pens if
anyone keeps pets and I've got cats
cat litter I mean if they've got 15 cat
pens 15 lots of cat litter and plus all
the dog poo where's it all going
what they're going to do with it it's
not in our report at all
no they're it it is obviously a
consideration counselor and chair but
they're it's covered by their license
effectively so they do need to dispose
of that responsibly
I don't know exactly how that will be
done but
sorry dispose of it responsibly but you
don't know how it's going to be done
sorry can I ask is is there nothing we
can ask about that you can't add
anything to that
I can't myself Chad no no
um well the other question was
um I've just looked at the previous
report on this report
and I was looking at the um
holsworthy hamlets where they say
counselors were hopeful that Devon
County Council highways would be
concerned about the increased traffic
movements now this came up last time
when we discussed this there were eight
kennels there'll be you know people
bringing their dogs collecting them all
right we decided that wasn't too big a
problem we're now talking about
increasing that to 15 cap pens and yet
Devon County still don't have a problem
with it I know we've got a Devon County
Traffic bloke here could he just say
something about that why is you don't
see that as an issue
excuse me
yeah just to clarify Chad the the
um the Horizon is correct they referred
to the standing advice the highways
Authority which delegates it to offices
effectively and that assessment is
undertaken on site um the as it as set
out in the report visibility at the
access is considered to be good
um and and obviously the surrounding
Highway Network can can comfortably
accommodate the level of traffic really
I mean it's it's not a single track lane
or anything like that you've got you've
got a 90 degree Bend further to the side
from the access which will obviously
slow traffic down approaching the site
but even on that bend you can have two
cars two vehicles that can comfortably
pass each other in either direction and
the same outside the site as well
Christie I assume the business will have
a commercial waste collection Point like
any other Commercial Business
um I don't know if you want to condition
that but I'm happy to Second character
leather is a proposition
that's something we can condition then
about the remove the waste
yeah we could certainly add a condition
requiring a
written confirmation of how weight will
be disposed and for that to be confirmed
prior to occupation
um but as as the case officer said that
there will be that will be controlled
through the license as well but we can
certainly add that as part of the
recommendation
I should say that um that there is
potential for 30 cats not 15 because
they can share each pen I gather so
while the councilors want to consider
whether that could be a problem in terms
of noise or smell
um I on a question of clarification I
see the council Parish Council refer to
some of the neighbors not being
consulted I don't know whether that's a
legal requirement or not whether alien
can advise us or James
yeah thank you chair
um yeah so the the parish councilor did
point that out and initially when the
application was validated there wasn't
wider consultation undertaken it was
still the coach was still undertook and
met his statutory function in terms of
putting a site notice up and and
um directly Consulting anybody that's
joining the red line but once obviously
we were alerted to that then we did and
take a wider consultation to a number of
properties within the local area
I mean like yeah my initial concern was
mixing dogs and cats as some of the
other councilors have said and I'm not
entirely convinced that you don't know
cats don't make a noise it is part of
the question whether there's separation
between the dogs and the cats and it
seems like there will be I mean I could
I was sort of envising a situation where
dogs would were loose and possibly
chasing cats but there has to be clear
separation I think and uh I think it was
a good kennels dog shouldn't be out on
the news
thank you
on that I mean if they say it's raining
cats and dogs in chillsworthy it could
be a problem couldn't it
whereas the flood Protection Officer
as an owner of three cats and one dog
um cats are habitually very quiet
cats and dogs can and do live together
and mix well
I'm hearing yes there is the potential
to have
30 cats there but I think realistically
it's going to be a lot less
and we're not looking at a constant
tooling and throwing of vehicles on a
daily basis people tend to go away for
three four five days or even two weeks
so you know it's not going to be
a hardship with traffic
no yeah I mean I've just got one query
[Music]
um
the proposed office and kitchen is that
all in one building or two separate
buildings
yeah thank you chair that's all in one
building I don't know if we can go back
to the um yeah the floor plans which are
yeah so that the bottom image there on
that slide the um the office is over on
the left hand side of that this is the
the plan at the floor plan and the
kitchen is over on the right hand side
and then between those there are the 15
pens where the cats would be
accommodated
and I noticed there was going to be no
sink in the kitchen which I thought was
rather you know for their own personal
hygiene
but does that come under license indoors
yes again that's covered by the licensed
chair they are required to have a
kitchen as I understand it from from
speaking to the um the licensing um
officer at Norwich they are required to
have a kitchen in terms of the
preparation of food but it doesn't need
to have be plumbed in ETC and they have
got a number of fresh water points
around the site really
um in terms of a number of taps
I only have a consumers on page um 62
the penultimate paragraph about
um the local councils
thinking that their comments were being
completely ignored but I mean I'd like
to pass on to the wall member and I
think myself will ring up that both
officers and plans committee members
would be well aware of any such comments
and would take them into consideration
when reaching the decision so I really
do think they ought to be made aware
that their comments are not completely
ignored
um I've had some experience
um where I'm from in the Midlands of
catteries and dog kennels
and very similar to this in near
Nottingham on the outskirts of
Nottingham and the kennels came first
the Cattery almost a replica of this uh
I'm not quite sure from the plan how far
the cat proposed Cattery is from the
current Kennels
I don't know if you can shed I think the
officer can confirm that yeah
but
um whilst the they may not be able to be
screening from proposed for the Cattery
from the kennels
it's sent
um not smell from but scent of the cats
I think as the experience I had in
Nottingham was that did create a problem
and and set the dogs
um barking quite noisily
thank you for those comments do you want
clarification to the distance between
the Cattery in the Kennels
yeah just to clarify chair there's
approximately 50 meters between the two
so if you look on the um on that red
line that's going from the Cattery up to
the third party dwelling is 72 meters so
it'll be approximately 50 meters between
the kennels and the Cattery
that's correct yeah both both um the the
kennels members may recall that they
were permitted with hedge banks in a
condition to construct those before the
uh the facility was brought into use and
the same with the category that the
Hedge banks are showing on the East and
western and southern sides and again
there's a condition requiring those to
be constructed prior to that facility
being brought into use
all right any further comments from
anyone else
in that case then it has been proposed
by accounts and they're executive by
Council Pennington that the applications
approved
along with the additional agreement
about removal of waste are you both
happy with that
yeah written confirmation of how waste
will be disposed yeah we can the case
officer can draft something and
circulate around to to members that's
right
so we now go to the vote for the
application to be approved
thank you chair councilor Christie
thanks
cancer Gibson
councilor Hackett
four
councilor Haynes
against
councilor leather
councilor Locke councilor Pennington for
councilor Smith
or councilor Wheatley for
that's six four and three against chair
so the application is approved thank you
very much
right application D on your agenda
application one stroke one three seven
eight of the brand is corner and it's on
pages 70 to 79 of your agenda
are there any Declarations of Interest
yes cancer sure I think I looked in the
for transparency
make something clear
um I used to live a mile from the site
at home or and it used to form part of
my ward and Kern Bridge the applicant is
known to me and I have collected Timber
from the site from one of the tenants
roughly between 2021 and 2022.
um
that that person who operated the
business in one of the units has now
left the site
I can judge this application with a
clear and open mind
like any other decorations of Interest
no I now ask the officer to give the
report then please
thank you chair
just wait for the slide
the application is for I suppose the
description is for the part
retrospective application for the
relocation and repair of existing
buildings part change of use of existing
building and the erection of a new steel
framed industrial shed underclass e
so moving on run through the slides and
the site location plans identified in
red there and so will it just to the
west of bovicott lane and then across
the south of the
plan you've got there is the main a road
sites bordered largely by trees and
sort of open space apart from the
residential dwelling to the South
so there's an aerial photos showing The
Wider context and sort of the wooded
area to the East and in the South shows
the residential property to the South as
well
and then the next slide should Zoom that
in a little more give you a better idea
of the context and
the roads and access to the site are
obviously obscured by the trees in this
and just for members information that
Google image was taken in 2021
and we move on to the proposed plans so
we've got site layout plan
the
plan shows five to five buildings
um we have
I run through them one by one
um there's one to the center of the site
which is known as building one and then
there's a red dotted line around that
that indicates
the applicant indicating that there was
an existing building there which they're
seeking to reposition
um building
two is to the South right on the
southern boundary again it's got a red
dotted line where the applicant is
indicating
that it's to replace an existing
building
building threes to the Western corner of
the site Southwestern corner and again
indicates that it's to be a replacement
for an existing building that's dotted
in red there
and then we have two further buildings
to the north buildings four and five
building four to the North Western
corner is noted as being an existing
shed
and building five is a proposed new
industrial shed as put in the
description
the application also includes permission
for the railings and brick Piers along
the boundary to the East and the gates
that are indicated on the plan there
again this is the plans are submitted by
the applicant they're indicating
the images previously of the various
sheds that were on site
I'm dotted in the red on the plans
then we run through the buildings this
is the replacement of building one
and a replacement for building two to
the south of the site
replacement shed for building three
which is on the western side
and that's the existing building shed 4
to the northwest of the site
and then finally the dimensions and
details of the proposed new industrial
shed to the north eastern corner of the
site
the applicant has also provided a
drainage plan originally we had some
concerns raised by our Environmental
Protection Officer in relation to foul
drainage from the site
and the applicant indicating that there
was an existing package treatment plant
on site
um which was noted on the plans and
they've now provided details of how this
will be discharged to the adjacent water
course and the Environmental Protection
Officer has removed their objection to
that
so just running through some photographs
and just to note that these are taken
these particular photographs were taken
in February 2022 so we can see the brick
piers and Boundary wall are sort of
under construction across the site and
the right hand photo there shows the
steel frame outline of what has now
become building two to the south of the
site
and moving on some more photos taken in
February 2022 the bottom photo there on
the left hand side you can see the
existing shed to the North Western
corner of the site
and again on the
right hand photo the skeleton of
building two that was under construction
at the time
and then just sort of panning rounds of
similar photos but again from
early 2022
and these photos are taken more recently
in fact this week so you can see the
boundary world has now been completed
with the railings and the views there of
building two to the south of the sites
which is now complete
and again panning around the site and
the left-hand photo there you can just
about see the shed in the North Western
corner but it's building four
and then it's panning around the site a
little more the right hand photo shows
access point onto the main a road from
bobacot Lane out onto the main a road
looking in One Direction and then
there's further photos of this as we go
along
so the right hand photo is looking back
towards
holdsworthy the left-hand photo looking
towards High Hampton and happily
and these are photographs taken by the
highways officer and I believe although
I'm happy to be corrected that these
were taken from a 0.2.4 meters back from
the junction so they illustrate the
visibility display for a vehicle
approaching that Junction
and then as I ran through with members
site visit just some aerial photographs
of the site in order to be able to
establish what the actual principle of
development is that we're looking at
here and what the actual development is
for
bearing in mind the retrospective nature
of parts of it and we've had to review
various aerial images and historic
photographs of the site so
this is back in 2021
um our aerial mapping our Council aerial
mapping shows on the left-hand side
there that there was a building under
construction
you probably see very faintly on the
south of the site
um and a building to the north of the
site but otherwise largely a Clear Sight
and I've just included the Google street
view images I'm here as well over some
of the time
just for context for members but they're
very similar to my photos
of early 2022
again just the Google street view images
and then we go back in time 2018 and
photograph there shows the three sheds
that are indicated on the submitted
plans as
previously being there
and likewise
two of two to three of those sheds are
also shown on 2015 Aero photographs it's
not entirely clear whether you can see
the sort of southern boundary of the
site there as to where the one building
exists I understand the site's
historically being used as a Timber yard
and that certainly indicated on these
aerial photographs was sort of piles of
wood that you can see
foreign
and again just for information and
there's some Google Street View
hopefully also has some 2009 images just
to show you how the site previously
appeared
so moving on to the material
considerations
um the principle of developments and
this is obviously discussed in some
detail in the officers report
further to an assessment of all the
aerial images your officers consider the
application to be for the items which
are put in the bullet points on page 74
of your agenda
so to extend beyond that which is set
out in the description
given the scale and nature of the
development in this location and your
officers consider that the principle of
development is contrary to policies st07
st11 and dm14 of the local plan
in terms of the impact on landscape and
character and appearance
taking account of the rural context of
Lane it's considered that the proposed
or now constructed Gates and railings
would be out of keeping with the
character and appearance of the
surrounding area
and therefore will be contrary to policy
dmo4
and relevant paragraph 130 of the mppf
and that's set out on page 75 of your
report
in terms of residential amenities it's
noted there is a neighbor
um residential neighbor immediately to
the south of the site and whilst their
rear boundary does above the site the
actual dwelling is set some 110 meters
further to the South
um
the council's Environmental Protection
Officer has recommended conditions in
relation to construction working hours
but otherwise considered
your officers consider it to be in
keeping with policy dmo1
in terms of access and parking I will
come back to this in a moment and ask
the highways officer to um to chip in if
that's okay
um in terms of skipping onto drainage
um as noted previously we've now got
confirmation of the foul drainage
Arrangements
so as a result condition sorry reason
for refusal number three which is set
out on your agenda would now fall away
and your officers consider there to be
adequate surface water drainage
in terms of ecology
um
any Cloud ecological appraisal has been
submitted and it notes the former yard
use of the site and the bare ground
recommendations are therefore made in
relation to timing construction works
and nighttime lighting
but these could be secured via a
condition if necessary
and so I will hand over to the highways
officer to cover off the the highway
points as
mentioned to members in the site visit
yesterday we have received some
additional information sort of late in
the day in relation to highways so I
think Mike's probably best place to to
review that for you
so I'm colorblind so if that's red or
green I have no idea I could use kind of
like nod
um chair this is your show but would it
help if I gave some overarching thoughts
would that be okay
so
um
the concern we have from the start is is
number one this is an existing access
the actual access from the site onto
bovicott Lane isn't really a problem
I've not raised objections with that the
concern that I've got is the
um access or the junction from
bothellcott Lane onto the a3072
and I said it is an existing access and
we do take that and because it take that
into consideration however there's a
number of things we also take into
consideration such as
the visibility at the um at the access
which is poor um I think Laura showed
you the photos
um from a distance of 2.4 back we would
normally we would normally defer to the
design manual for rows and bridges dmrb
which is suitable for 60 mile an hour
routes
um and and that would be 250 meters to
the left oh sorry to the right there's
35 meters which is less than what we'd
expect in the 30 mile an hour limit to
the um sorry that's to the right to the
left it's zero there's zero visibility
as as that um
um
photo demonstrated so that's number one
secondly the fact is that there are
light traffic movements um I went out
yesterday for about half an hour from 11
30 till 12 I saw four vehicle movements
two of those were the postman coming and
going one of those was either visitor or
the owner of the site just inside
bobblecott Lane and the fourth one was a
another so very few traffic movements
um the the third part is the problem of
the e3072 it is part of the high speed
Network it's subject to the National
speed limit I've spoken to our data team
who have done traffic counts albeit some
years ago but speeds don't really
generally change that much and we are
talking about an 85th percentile which
is the market for like higher traffic
speeds of of about mid 50s so that's
there's that concern as well
it is correct to say that the um when we
look at collisions the evidence space we
use is the um Collision database that's
compiled by the police you've all got
access to that go home and Google it or
use another search engine but just put
in Devon County Devon Collision records
and that will come up
there isn't any reported crashes on
there and I highlight reported because
um effectively what is registered is if
you would have a knock with somebody
else the police turned up then we
recorded if if you just exchange details
and be on your way then like it's not
reported so it is reported crashes
slight problem we have is that if we
increase traffic movements through an
existing Junction
um is that going to cause a problem and
it's not just the number it's also the
the type of vehicle we're looking at as
well so would there be more for example
slower moving hgvs that kind of material
that kind of material change
and what I would add to that as well is
if you look at other Junctions in the
approximate area such as Waterloo Road
which is close to the holdsworthy
Brandis Corner the a3079 where it meets
the O3 a3072
where there is limited or or
um uh in different visibility splades we
have got Collision records at those
three Junctions so obviously the concern
is if we increase traffic movements or
certain types of traffic are we
therefore going to increase collisions
here as well
so
the other thing I would say is we
as you'll see from my recommendation it
wasn't and I'm sorry can I just actually
just say one other thing because I do
collect inspect a bit of a nerd when it
comes to inspectors decisions
um and and I do collect these and I
refer you to one from the planner
inspector an inspector said a similar
application
um it is possible nonetheless that the
lack of accidents might be explained by
the relatively low levels of traffic
currently used in Junction as in as
indicated by the the applicant survey of
traffic levels on the lane and born out
in my visit the absence of any reported
accidents
would not in itself be a good reason for
accepting the standard the visibility
which as in the case of this appeal for
substantially below the recommended
level okay so and that appeal was
dismissed
so what I would say is
um the recommendation response we put in
was absolutely wasn't the no it was look
we need more information here and what
we normally look at is um either through
a design access statement transport
assessment
transport statement for larger um larger
developments we are effectively for more
information looking at the trip
generation that's going to be attracted
so and forgive me for people with longer
than the truth on planning committee
just just for the new members all
development has a degree of trip
Generation
Um we generally say for example a single
dwelling is six straight car movements
um that's that's one in one out would be
like like the Pokemon yesterday would be
two a holiday unit we three to five in
agricultural buildings one to two so
there would be a trip generation
attracted to each of these um proposed
units or if if indeed they change in
nature so effectively what I was asking
for this is over 12 months ago I will
point out is an idea of of what kind of
levels of vehicles or what types of
vehicles we're expecting and what kind
of levels of traffic movement we're
looking at
the email that Laura referred to a
moment ago has come in and they've had
they've started to have a bit of a fist
of actually putting some traffic
movements together
um it's not a finished article it's not
what you would really accept as an
Evidence base but it's it's moving in
the right direction the second thing I
would add as well is they are proposing
to improve um the junction of bother cut
Lane and the 3072 it's not really
anything more than the cigarette pack
design at the moment but nevertheless
you know that that's a possibility and
again that would be that that may well
be reasonable mitigation against the
impact of the development
so I think that's just an overarching
idea of of where I am with it so why am
I like is it the chair Council hasn't
got any Highway questions you would like
to put to it
yes
um
your last comment about
Junction improvements at bubblecott Lane
understanded I was Ward counselor out
there
and um when it was current Bridge Ward
and the next Junction along with Brandis
corner was seen as by the parish council
at Bradford Cooper has been highly
dangerous and they were trying to get
Junction improvements there for many
many years because of the dangerous near
misses you know it's right on the corner
with the pub the pub being an issue
there you couldn't move a listed
building even when it was burnt down it
had to be on the same footprint I'm
absolutely astounded that something's
going to happen or propose to happen on
the back of a bag package I hear you say
at that Junction sorry can I just
clarify I'm just saying that they've
um I I sorry I didn't mean to be
derogatory about what they're proposing
is that it's a first introduction
effectively you know they've they've
come they've come with a design and I I
should be positive about it because
they've come forward with the design of
actually improving the access to try and
mitigate against the impact of the
development okay so I would say that
just just rewinding this is a little
easier because they've got access over a
public Highway and B
um uh from what I understand from the
email they've got success or there's an
agreement to use the private land that's
directly adjacent to it we never had and
we don't have that nicety at Browns
corner so
okay notwithstanding that there's got to
be some sort of
reorganization I put it that of that
access
um so that's the first thing
and again sorry I I don't mean to just
um pull the rug from under your feet
um that the example I always give and
again forgive me this is for new members
on the on the um committee so if for
example we had a factory
with absolutely shocking
um if with with shocking access that
would have a trip generation attached to
it if for example they say well I'm
going to get rid of the factory and
we're going to build houses on it if
they could demonstrate that the vehicle
movements were equal to or less than
what that factory would generate then
we're kind of although we don't like the
access we're slightly snookered because
it's not making the situation any worse
so again
the only caveat I put on that is at the
moment we don't know it's like I said
sorry to sound like Donald Rumsfeld but
it's a bit of an unknown at the moment
sort of thing okay now you'll be aware
that the gradient of the lane after the
industrial site descends very rapidly in
fact on Ordinance survey Maps you will
see it's got
the the arrows
marking the severity of the gradient and
it goes to a very narrow humpback bridge
and then goes up an even steeper
gradient to home or where I used to live
it's a single track very narrow Lane is
there a weight limit over the bridge
no
um and I speak to our Bridge Engineers
about this sort of thing quite often
because some of the Ricky Jones looking
look at Ricky this looking old bridges
actually could take quite happily 44
Turners on a regular basis you know so
it's it's
um appearance always does always say um
spell out what the actual real situation
is and it's quite possible I said that
that bridge is absolutely fine and
they've got no concerns about it and the
fact there's no great restriction on it
suggests that's the case as well okay
because if you were sat
at the industrial proposed industrial
site
and you wanted to go to
um to the north to stip cross your Sat
Nav would take you the shortest
direction to go down that way now if you
had something coming in a direction you
would have a major problem there as I
did yesterday with the tractor I had to
refresh some somewhere it's a rural
farming absolutely there and I would
suggest that anybody who
as a driver and if I knew the road I
would come out of the access of the
proposed development that side hanger
right hang another right and go around
Brown's corner I think is it because the
road is far better you've got two you've
got two lane movement the whole way
rather than risk being
um meter tractor or or similar yeah okay
um one final question at this point yes
you said there's a lack of visibility on
that long sweeping Bend and I know from
using that
um Lane before you've got to be very
very careful from when you pull out but
if you go further on down traveling
towards the East View direction towards
High Hampton you have got
um Ruby Oak and Ruby Oak have put up no
turning notices I don't know if you're
all aware of them at their entrance
they've got no turning marked so they
have obviously got a reason for putting
that there I don't think that's rather
irrelevant to what we're talking about
now really because we're talking about
the entrance that people are missing the
turning to bothersburg going on and
coming back well that's the individual
drivers but he cannot yeah
I'm highlighting there is an issue here
about traffic movement okay thank you
yes
um thank you for your report Michael
um it's very useful voice again and
hearing your case study you just brought
in
my concern about highways here is being
proportionate unenforceable okay you
have a brain for your site
already in existence already in use
now putting myself in the position of
the applicant
I would put the traffic movements in
history as the highest I possibly could
before I started this application how
can you check historic
movements so therefore you move on to
the next question
how can you then enforce if you have no
measurement to enforce and that's where
your your difficulty is going to lie and
I just liked some explanation how you're
going to overcome that problem it really
depends how the
um how like an Evidence space will come
forward effectively I've spoken to Laura
about this before she's deliberately
not making eye contact right now but
um
is trying to determine what the previous
what is the x-stamp planning permission
for the site you know we've had that we
have had this conversation so
effectively that's going to need to be
determined and and this is where I'm
gonna
do the slope you should think slightly
sorry it's the it's for the planning
authority to decide what the extent
planning permission is for the site and
then we can make a determination on on
what what the proposed development is
and therefore ago what what the um what
the likely traffic movements will be
um that's effectively where we are so so
you know trying to figure out what it's
used for what it's reasonably been used
for and I said what it will be used for
and what the difference will be and like
I said from that we can determine
whether it's my Factory uh example from
earlier or where there is there is going
to be a clear increase
I can emphasize this already an existing
Brownfield site in use and are you going
to hamstring a business when you can't
really enforce any decision on highways
Precision thank you chair
right I think we've given the highway
sorry
yeah and um were you quite right I mean
there will be for sure
um employees if they're say for example
um but you know the concern I had
pulling out yesterday and I did I did
the kind of like the circuit quite a few
times is
um
physically to the right you can kind of
like nose your way out visibly to the
left uh you're pretty much in the center
of the carriageway before you can see
what's coming you know or you can't born
this is anyway so so that was a concern
I had um so yeah you're right like I
said it we would expect some kind of
idea in any
um design access segment transport
statement whatever you want to call it
um to to give an idea of what kind of
vehicles are going to be using it
right I think we've given the highways
officer a good oh sorry sorry guys
Smith thank you chair
um how much importance do you put on the
visual display
um uh it strikes me these days that um
you go into many roundabouts in this
area you have signage blocking the
visual display
um and this instance we're putting far
more
emphasis on the fact you can't see it it
effectively slows traffic down which is
a good thing and I completely understand
that but in some instances we seem to be
deliberately blocking the visual display
we shouldn't and please report anywhere
where you think that is the case not to
me right here right now but but
um but like I said no no we
um
um Highway engineering 101 is is keep
your visible experience clear so like I
said that
please do yeah yeah
right I think we've given that Highway
obviously a very good grilling
so I know I go to the public speakers
list our first speaker is gather short
speaking in support
I'm late thank you thank you chair uh
good morning committee members thanks
for providing the uh opportunity to
speak in favor of this plan application
my name is Gareth short and I represent
the agent R.A Rowe for the application
um a lot of the details just been
covered there but I'll go for the points
I've made so the subject type uh subject
site rather bothecut yard represents a
parcel of land which has been used for a
significant number of years for
commercial purposes as the blind officer
has pointed out the last commercial use
of the site is by a local company a
fence line UK around 2018
um they operated their business from the
yard for a number of years it is
understood and evidenced by photographic
record that at least one of the existing
sheds that was on the building suffered
fire damage and that shed could be seen
on one of the earlier slides
um this ultimately led to that building
being removed for health and safety
reasons essentially the planned
application looks to reinstate the
buildings on the site albeit with
adjustments to their footprint position
and additional shed that was already
covered the Crux of the application
appears to be a lack of evidence to
suggest what the yard has been
previously useful Laura and I have had
quite a lot of discussion about this
it's been tricky to try and find all the
evidence we needed but it can be
concluded from previous planning records
and recent history the site does have a
long-standing and meaningful
commercial-based history
policy dm14 makes reference to proposals
being supported where they will enhance
existing rural services and economies
this proposal will provide opportunity
for existing local businesses to expand
and grow while also supporting other
local businesses making up our important
rural economy
um some other matters which have
generally been covered but the
Environmental Protection Officer is now
in receipt the information regarding
um suitable means of our water disposal
from the sewage treatment plant and
concerns have been raised from a highway
officer perspective regarding the
existing Highway Junction which we just
heard about and I agree with the
concerns that have been raised and
apologize that the additional
information hasn't been provided with
regards to trip data however the
applicant has done a significant amount
of work with joining landowners
regarding the forthcoming Improvement of
existing access sight lines and I think
they've referred to I'd done a little
drawing really just to illustrate the
visibility can be improved particularly
to the left which is the high Hampton as
the highway officer just suggested it is
poor that's the poorest the right hand
side is not as bad but there is there is
a scheme on the table to improve the
visibility to the left
um and then just to recap the some of
the benefits the site can be consider
Brownfield previously established land
I say is there's a history of that site
being used for commercial industrial for
a long long time the application poses
many benefits to local area and more
importantly the rural economy and can be
interpreted as being broadly compliant
with policy St 11
and we live in current times where local
families local people are more Reliant
than than ever yeah yep sorry on sound
employment opportunities which the
application would undoubtedly provide a
significant enhancement to in support of
the rural rural economy thank you very
much
thank you
thank you chair thank you good morning
commission
I feel like I should just pick up a
little bit on the highways report I know
the area like the back of my hand
because just up from that site is the
Homestead of Professor Robert Patterson
which I visited quite regular and I'm
used to coming out of that low Junction
I would come out of that low Junction a
hundred times more than I would come out
with a brandish Corner one which is a
nightmare and the highways would do
nothing about it so the the low Junction
is not quite as bad as it's painted and
I believe that there is an opportunity
to improve that access
so that shouldn't be an issue it's quite
simply but it's unfortunately it's not
been put to highways earlier and a lot
of this should have been dealt with
slightly earlier than it has been
and in particular the use of the yard
which is about what it was worse than a
Bloomfield site it was like a scrap yard
but when it was being used
there was something like 20 people
employed in The Sawmill business as well
as some other storage
and as you know
the large lorries that go in and over
there carrying logs because although it
was built
in the wooded area
um I'm told primarily to build boats for
the Armada for Plymouth so we are going
back a little bit in its use but in
recent times all the wood is taken there
and they obviously some will know that
the Sawmill business has moved to
Bridgeville and onto the virtual
industrial site and we have lorries in
and out and I say we because they use my
Farm Lane they're in and out every day
with Timber and taking Widow so I think
the highways issues can be addressed
it's also an unusual Road in so much as
it's an estate road that was adopted by
Devon County and the reason it looks
like a Motorway is because the residents
of that road enforce the Covenant upon
Devon County and they had to rebuild it
and resurface they did decline to do it
but there is a covenant a full contract
when they adopted the road to actually
maintain it to a standard that's
agreeable to the residents and that's
why and it was brought up in Bradford
Bradford parish council meeting why when
there's so many potholes this particular
Road looks like a Motorway and it's
nothing to do with the maintenance of
normal roads is to do with a covenant
that goes with it the use of it so if I
could just clarify that
going on to it and I could keep you
there all day but I've got a meeting
about um Royal Prosperity eight half
past one so we're crack on
as far as I'm concerned the M14 it
supports fraud development and it's a
headline I've put here the government's
role
England Prosperity fund
and the quote is the ultimate ambition
for the spec the spending to help
improve productivity and strengthen the
rural economy and Rural communities
so we are looking at a site that was
been used for years
it becomes slightly derelict the
applicant
cleaned it up and so when you see the
slides you see what looks like it could
be a new development but it's actually
part of the clearing up of the site and
although I'm not allowed to show you I
could show you photographs of what it
was like before it was cleared up and
they should have gone to the officer
weeks ago so I'm supporting it because
it does do that
um
the change change of use
or the conversion within dm14 it says
the change of use and conversion of
permanently and secondly
constructed soundly constructed
buildings well I think if you've seen
the previous state of it you wouldn't
have agreed they were particularly so
so it's all buildings are joining
well-related or defined settlements or
rural settlements
um so I can't even read my own writing
this morning
um
should be considered now that lane leads
up to wholemore which is only a few
hundred yards and that's not shown
and as I say the lane has actually got
history to it but it does go directly
into Hormel and then into Bradford so it
is related to a joining areas
um and as I say I do know the area like
the back of my hand
um
and also the post-development
has a strong functional link to local
agricultural forestry or other existing
rural activities whether one building
that's been constructed
will be for the sale and maintenance of
quads and four-wheel drive vehicles
which to my mind are directly related to
agriculture
right
I did bring the wrong glasses I've got
the driving glasses on I'm sorry
um
it's not for reading the page I can't
believe this but anyway anyway I'll
forget what I wrote and just say that
this is a bone-filled site it's been
used for all sorts of uses over the
years it become direct when the soil
business moved out and went to the new
site and
as far as I can say it actually more
Prosperity it is situated very close and
we've just had two applications to do
with the M14 in rural areas two meetings
ago we discussed a
accountants building in the countryside
and one of the discussions was about
Farmers all going there with their
accounts as we all know that's involved
in farming and business all our accounts
are done on the HR hmrc website so we I
haven't been to my accountants which is
why Sally house has been for sale I
haven't been there for four years we
just don't do that so that was a failure
to recognition what is happening and
then last time we approved a dwelling at
the Brandis Corner Garage which is a few
hundred yards up from there which is a
thriving business that Services the
whole area and the interesting thing
about that and this site is it's just
next to the Howell Road that goes to
okhampton Exeter and then the M5 so we
are looking at
an area that has good access to the
wider area as well as to the local area
so I'm not going to bore you with all
the details
if the visit I understand the drainage
has been of the three things which I
haven't bought with me the drainage has
been sorted out the visibility can be
sorted out and as I say I don't consider
it to be particularly bad
and the only thing left with is our
dreaded st07
which is really a wet blanket on the
rural Countryside so I'll rest it there
and save you the embarrassment that I
can't read my own notes
thank you chair
thank you Council James
right then I now throw the matter open
for discuss discussion but listening to
everything that has been said
the applicants do seem to be working
towards traffic movements what sorts of
vehicles and they are hoping to improve
that Junction
should we not agree to a deferral until
we've got more information on what the
improvements they're doing
I'll put that to members here's Christie
yeah I'd agree with that and I'd also
I have a real problem with this because
it says in our agenda proposals change
of use to existing buildings but it
doesn't say what and I've just heard
from the Ward member it's going to be
retailing and yet I read on page 75 that
about the class E which you're applying
for only covers industrial uses
can we get that clear as well because
I'm amazed that I've just heard it's
going to be retail outlet in the middle
of nowhere
I think
oh I think the change of use was from
sort of the Agriculture and Forestry use
but the proposal is to change it to
class E which as you'll no counselor
covers quite a wide range of uses and
you're quite right it goes from retail
includes everything in terms of
Financial and Professional Services that
we used to have in the old class A2
includes medical and Health Services
crashes and then goes into Light
Industry and offices so it is quite a
broad brush that they have proposed so
it does include retailing
within Class A yes it does
yeah and just just to add to that what
it wouldn't Encompass is that sort of
vehicle repair motor vehicle
um type use wouldn't fall within any
class it could be three generous certain
elements could be B2 used so I think
there does need to be Clarity on exactly
what what is proposed okay
[Music]
Curtis Bennington by by deferring do we
risk non-determination
okay
um of course councilor Pennington there
always is a risk that the applicant
could
appeal for non-determination I think the
committee need to be very clear on why
they're deferring the application and
what additional information they wish
for the applicant to provide because
that should give them some clarity and
certainty too to the applicant in terms
of what is needed the application has
been in for a considerable amount of
time and as you've heard there are
additional areas of information that are
needed so
my my feeling would be that there would
hopefully be a low risk of such an
appeal but I I think the committee needs
to be very clear on why they're
deferring and what additional
information that the highway matters
form one of the reasons for refusal but
there are two other reasons for refusal
one around design and one around the
principle of development so I I think
from an officer point of view speak out
of turn here
it's quite possible that additional
information is not going to satisfy that
first reason for refusal so any
application that's brought back to you
that the highway reason may fall away we
don't know at this point however there
would still be other other reasons that
you would need to be considering as well
may I respond
yeah thank you for response um put it
clear from that point of view I've just
got a little concern that we're using
the M14 when dm14 is quite clear to
support the rural economy new small
Economic Development our rural
settlements and it's a new small scale
and the plan
is silent over existing businesses who
want to move forward put new buildings
in and go with the future and I can't
find
anything like dm14 that fits this
application because dm14 really by its
first sentence is struck out and that is
a struggle to actually apply the plan to
this situation so I have a real
difficulty here
secondly I don't think it's enforceable
um Michael for your work with highways
you're going to get in a situation where
you can demonstrate this not enforceable
um or they argue that's not enforceable
so that's going to be interesting
argument as well and I notice on the
recommendation too the brick wall and
the railings I mean that's a matter of
um I quite like that railing it looked
quite nice you knew you were looking at
an industrial site you know and you're
looking at something that clearly said
this is a business that's in use and
design and
appearance is something very subjective
so I I accept then know that I will vote
with you guys to defer but there's a lot
there that I want to say that this
should really be passed in the light of
where we are but I will vote with the
deferment on that situation
you got blood
I just you know it was all right when
it's like green sheds and um sort of
small scale business doing Timber and
stuff but this is on a much bigger scale
in my mind and the impact on the
countryside location is is much greater
um and I'm obviously concerned about the
highways issue and how much traffic is
going to be generated there's like
likely to be private cars from what
we've
what we've understood that there will be
a retail outlet there
um I have concerns I think the visual
aspect of the wall is sort of like a
Suburban wall rather than a rural
context so I would go along with with
the officer's recommendation really and
propose
that we refuse it on the grounds offer
body officers except for the paragraph
on foul drainage which has been covered
I think
foreign proposal to be peers
no second sorry
chair
we seem to have a bit of a Limbo with
this um
clearly we want more information and for
whatever reason this building has all
this complex is being built over a
number of years
without planning permission I do
understand
the legality behind all that but as we
have a recommendation from the officers
to refuse
have enforcement put a stop notice on it
so it doesn't get further developed
as far as I went I'm aware the
Enforcement Officers know about the site
I don't know whether there's a specific
stop notice on it but they're certainly
aware of it
thank you chair yeah whilst we're
getting the presentation and then when
Michael was speaking it was occurring to
me about deferring this application
because we do need more information on
the highway aspect and it sounded from
the applicant when he spoke that they
are looking to address that we don't
know what the traffic uses along there
we might get a bit more information as
well or naturally what you what the site
is used for and what it's proposed to be
used for councilor James did mention
foreign
those little things that they run around
number
that's it yeah and that was it that was
it that was obviously the Kawasaki
building that we all saw on the
photographs so you know there's quite a
bit more information we could have
reading them ppf great store weight is
given to Brownfield sites being
developed and this is definitely my view
of brownfield's side so I think you're
very sensible I don't think there's any
risk of non-determination the applicant
I'm sure is happy to provide the extra
bit that you know will give us more
clarity
so it does the confirm with the planning
manager do we have to State our reasons
for deferring yes I I think not least
for clarity for the the applicant and
the agent to know what what additional
information that you wish to see
um if I could just sort of summarize the
some of the discussions so in terms of
the relevant policies policy dm14
um your right councilor Pennington does
refer to New small-scale Economic
Development in the countryside however
there are New Uses proposed here it is a
change of use and there are new
buildings proposed so your officers
would consider that policy to be
relevant and it's important to note that
the glossary defines small scalars up to
200 square meters so I'm just sort of
giving information here policy st07 part
four
is relevant and that that talks about
Development coming forward exceptionally
to serve local needs and there is a
question around a very broad Class E
proposal and both the mppf and our
policies requiring development to meet
identified local needs so you may want
to understand some more information
about potential end users there is a
concern over certainly the the use that
has already been described as being on
site and whether that would actually
fall within classy so the applicant may
want to have a think about
I think that'd be sort of pointless
committee approving something when
actually you've you've got something on
site that could potentially not fall
within that used class and I believe the
case officer has been seeking further
information on the uses that are likely
to be seen on the site and finally what
I would today is as Council Leathers
referred to the mppf that is part of
your decision-making context but it is
really important that you consider the
plan and the mppf as a whole and
certainly paragraph 85 does support and
place great weight on brownford land and
proved to develop land however other
parts of of the mppf identify yes there
should be substantial weight to
Brownfield development but it shouldn't
conflict with other policies in the
framework our own policy sto2 in the
local plan
at party puts a focus on using
previously developed land but equally at
part C it indicates that development
should come forward in sustainable
locations so I think there is this broad
picture that I you know I would just
urge the committee to to look at that
bigger picture as and when it comes back
right then so if we State our reasons
for deferrals Highway Junction
improvements traffic movement and types
of movement and potential end users
do you agree with those three reasons
for deferral
should we take a vote to do further the
application then so it has been
is cancer penitent does that mean then
that we were approving this application
because that's contrary to the con the
uh um recommendations here put in do you
want to
look at other issues there or do you
just did no no that's fine so we're just
saying highways is the one issue yeah no
we're not saying that
so it comes back to this committee
um with all the considerations to be
discussed again but with this further
information yeah
so that has been proposed by myself
executive by councilor Christie that oh
sorry Becky pardon
just like to add because the great
weights being um
put on the access problems at the
junction
um but the width of the lane between the
junction and the application site is
quite narrow and boarded heavily by
quite mature trees and looking at Google
Earth
um either side of the lane the roads the
verges are very soft and the camber of
the road which is in excellent condition
um again illustrates that if there's
larger Vehicles going down there
something's got to give way there's no
way for them to give way
and not easy to reverse an hgv
especially if it's an articulated
vehicle visiting the larger site
so
in terms of the recommendations if it's
possible to have a an area where
Vehicles can pass
between the junction and the application
site I just like to add that
well that will be something that will
come up when the application is brought
back to committee with highways
updates thank you
all right so can we take a recorded vote
that is on deferring the application
thank you chair councilor Christie
or
councilor Gibson or councilor Hackett or
counselor Haynes
councilor leather
Council a lot for councilor Pennington
or counselor Smith
councilor Wheatley four unanimous chair
fetty pharaoh
right moving on to application e
application number one zero zero two
zero zero the garage I pickensen and
it's on pages to 85 of your agenda are
there any Declarations of Interest
as the applicant and his family are
known to me and for complete Clarity I
will leave I will take no part in the
discussion or the decision and I will
leave the format of the committee
thank you
right we have this application taking
tempera regarding a garage come here
order please thank you
um we've had declaration any
Declarations of Interest we've had that
um can I ask the officer now to give a
report
good afternoon
members and members of the public
uh item 7e application one forward slash
zero zero two out 2023 forward slash ful
ton you can't hear me
um
so part retrospective application for
garage and Garden Room at 15 Church
Meadow High beckington
this is a part retrospective so as in
it's being partly built it's subject to
enforcement
the applicant believed that it didn't
require planning permission
but it does because it's less than two
meters away from the boundary of the
neighboring property
so it's been called into plans committee
can't hear me
okay
um so it's been called into plans
committee due to concerns about the
impact on the neighboring property
uh in particular having an overbearing
impact and
an impact on the enjoyment of the garden
for the neighbor
um there's also concerns about design
a fight plan
my next slide
so the site plan shows hopefully the
agent has put the distances on the site
plan so I've sort of zoomed in there to
show
the distance is so 12 meters from the
corner of the neighboring
party
next slide please
so floor plans elevations
next slide
so it's partially built they've stopped
building it it will be finished painted
white render
slate roof
and and windows
on the side yeah so uh that's a photo of
the applicant's garden the remaining
Garden area so you can see there's quite
a lot of space remaining
photo from the streets
next slide
so this is a photo from the neighbor
neighbor's side
and that's a
a montage of the neighbor's Garden so
put three photos together
with the Red Arrows where the garage is
and there's a photo from inside the
neighbor's house
so material planning considerations
it has in principle support from policy
DM 25 of the local plan ancillary
development
perfectly acceptable design and
character cannot be seen from the street
it's not particularly out of character
with other garages in the area it's
subservient to the main house
in terms of residential amenity which is
the Crux of this decision
um
the policy says that development will be
supported where it would not
significantly harm the amenities of any
neighboring occupiers
so my decision has been based on whether
the impact is significant
and in terms of permitted development if
it was a meter away from the boundary
um it would it wouldn't need planning
permission sorry another meter away from
the boundary so
[Music]
um
so that is a material consideration so
unfortunately
I do sympathize with the neighbor and
the objections that um
the view from the bifold doors but in
terms of planning there's no right to
review
so I have considered that
in terms of access and parking this has
not changed
ecology we're attaching a condition
for a bad box
also there's a condition attached that
no trade or business can be carried out
and sorry or it cannot be an independent
dwelling so
um
my recommendation would be to approve
the application
thank you
right we have two public speakers uh
Irene butcher
who's against he'd like to come down
speak three minutes
good morning my name's Irene Butch and I
live next door to 15 Church Meadow
we moved into our new house in June
2022.
by the middle of July it was obvious a
building was being erected just 1.1
meter away from the boundary fence
whole structure is now 8.8 by 5.2 by 3.9
meters at highest point with Eve's
height of 2.7 meters the proposed
battens and slave will obviously add
more height
no application of planning permission
has been made to the council the
applicant became aware of this situation
and told us it was permitted development
we contacted the planning department and
an investigation was instigated at the
end of October which deemed planning
permission was required
we reviewed the application and many
erroneous and frankly deceptive
statements were made including comments
made in the design and access statement
the submitted document documentation
gave erroneous States
no mention of the toilet window
overlooking our garden
errors in terms of ownership land
ownership
importantly an inaccurate measurement of
the distance from our boundary
stated at 25 meters it is 1.1 meter
couldn't have been a decimal place
mistake because it would have been 2.5
meters still incorrect
our understanding is that any planning
application must be determined in
accordance with the relevant policies of
an adopted development plan which in
this case is the north Devon and
torridge local plan
the most relevant policies are dm01
amenity conditions considerations
importance of protecting residential and
other amenities
and dm04 design principles
which you'll be aware of
the report refers to what could be
permitted development but the proposal
before you is not permitted development
and it is therefore in your gift to
refuse the application on its planning
merits taking into account the
legitimate concerns of Neighbors
on its individual merits The Proposal
very clearly has a very overbearing
impact on our property as its size and
height so close to our boundary results
in loss of light to a large part of our
rear Garden contrary to the case
officer's assessment and it again it is
contrary to d101 and dm04
as a final Point again contrary to the
report the building cannot be said to be
subservient neighboring dwelling houses
there are no other material
considerations that would suggest that
the council makes a decision other than
in accordance with its own adoptive
policies and on that basis the
application should be refused as being
contrary to your own Council policies
thank you thank you
thank you very much
um can I ask Kathy Bradley to come out
thank you
speaking for Mr Andrew butcher
um
who's not well enough to be here
firstly this garage is practically
complete rather than as stated in the
committee report partially built
the north Devon and torridge local plans
support for development stroke building
within the high vickington development
boundary appears to have taken precedent
over the more laudable requirements of
policies st04 and dm-25
the garage building has significantly an
adversely impacted on my amenities
I'm not finding it unfortunate to have a
view of the whole garage from my bifold
doors rather I'm incredulous
the kitchen Diner is designed to open up
onto the seating area of our L-shaped
Garden
the garage Which is far from being a
thing of beauty runs along the width of
this section
both parties are rather subjectively
judged to have adequate space for the
enjoyment of their Gardens
the applicants eating City sitting area
is as far away from the garage as it's
possible to be
whereas it's just over a meter away from
mine
in reality one property has been
enhanced by impacting negatively on
another
which is contrary I think to the
criteria of dm25 there being no
significant adverse impact on the
immunity of the occupants of neighboring
properties
I believe that our legitimate
expectations regarding the use of our
garden space have neither been
safeguarded nor considered
the report states that there is no right
to a viewing planning
but apparently I have no right either to
have to object to having one foisted on
me
the prescribed area for a one-bedroom
shower room dwelling is just one square
meter or 2.7 percent greater than this
garage
the former would require a boundary
distance of two meters
therefore proportionately I would expect
the boundary distance in this case
should be at least 1.95 meters
the 1.1 meter boundary is considered
adequate for maintenance and it ensures
that the pitch roof does not overhang my
garden
am I meant to be reassured by this
there is an advised condition to ensure
the building is not used as a separate
dwelling or for business activities
but also advice
to the effect that a separate planning
application would be required to convert
this to a dwelling house or detached
Annex
finally I can categorically and honestly
state that had we known about this
construction which we should have done
and been aware of our lack of Rights we
would not have purchased up purchased
our house just under a year ago
please refuse the application thank you
very much Andrew butcher thank you very
much thank you
okay we've had the speakers are now open
up discussion on this application uh
councilor Hackett yeah
um
I can understand
the comments of the two speakers
however
I think
the excellent report you've done Debbie
summarizes the situation perfectly could
we go back to one of the slides that
shows the back one again there was one
of the overlooking of the
the actual toilet
to the garden
um it might have been forward a couple
right so we
yeah I think they're
there is the toilet window
to make sure that
we could lose the overlooking aspect if
we deem it overlooking could be
conditioning there'd be frosted glass in
that window
and
could we condition the roofing to be
matching slate
to the building to the left
so that's in keeping
I might have blocked you out let's try
again
right um yeah so um the agent has
confirmed that the window will be less
than
lower than the fence top of the fence
um for some reason it is shown like that
at the moment but it will be lower and
on the plans it's shown as lower than
the fence
um in terms of the Slate it's on the
plans but we could condition it as well
yeah
um just following on from the case
officer
given the window is to serve a toilet is
that right Debbie uh
um
but you know if members wish then a
condition could be added requiring that
to be obscure closing and
um whilst there is a condition
recommending completion of the
development in accordance with the plans
to secure that material and additional
condition could be added requiring the
roof material to be
slate to match the main driving
I think that would mitigate
the concerns I'm you know
I think for us as a committee to
to refuse this
and it went to appeal
I don't think it's a sustainable
position because I see it I see it as
the the report it's con it's conforming
to policy so I would be happy to propose
that we Grant this
with those two conditions
got a second to fill up
pose approved with the two conditions
councilor Gibson you seconding right
any other comments councilor Christie
yeah um one feels a lot of sympathy with
the neighbor
um I find it odd that the applicant
has done this because he actually runs a
building firm and you do hope you know
Builders do know
the law about these things
um the thing that strikes me however
when I saw the photographs was the
height of the roof can you explain it
because it does refer to it in the
report that it's
um was it 3.8 meters the height of 2.6
meters to the eaves and yet somewhere
else it says it's more than 2.5 meters
in height
what's our ruling on this
so um in in terms of permitted
development had the the building being
um well it's within two meters of a
neighbor's boundary and permitted
development would only allow the height
to be up to 2.5 meters without needing
planning permission so it's not a policy
position it's a permitted development
position because the the building is
within two meters and the height is
greater this is what triggers planning
permission and then it becomes an
assessment against our design and
amenity policies had with as the case
officer indicated if the building was
moved 90 centimeters or outside of that
two meter proximity to the boundary
um I think it's the case and correct me
if I'm wrong Debbie that the eaves
could be up to 2.5 meters so it is
slightly over the eaves anyway but
marginally but at a height up to four
meters an outbuilding can be if it's
outside of that two meter but this is
all permitted development it's not a
policy assessment
mm-hmm
like yeah sorry can I just query the
description of the application it says
Garden Room but obviously got a toilet a
sitting room and can we just clarify
that I mean
it's not quite clear whether it's a
garage or whether it's something else it
seems to me
um
my day room let's see
so it's not a substantial space
and there is a condition on it isn't
there for you know
uh any other we've had a proposal
executive Council leather
yeah a bit of a mystery for me this one
because keep people keep mentioning this
toilet this lavatory whereas the foul
drainage where is it sure level there's
no lavatory shore on the plant
it's not in the description either and I
looked at the application form and it
doesn't mentioning anything about having
a lavatory in there
but what's the drainage for a lavatory
if there is going to be gone not sure
I I and I also don't like the fact that
the metal profile roof which is in the
original application is now going to
have battens on top and slate on top of
that which again raises the roof it's a
bit of a cobble together scheme to me
huh
um it's a huge garage at the length of
it
8.8 meters 8.6 meters long tail of a
size I don't think if that metal roof
wasn't there and it was batons and
slates that would automatically lower it
a bit
um
thereby reducing the effect on the
neighbor
but I I
without knowing about this lavatory in
here and the drainage for that I I'm not
going to support you are you asking for
more information
well or they reapply and it's all
showing exactly what and take off this
stupid metal cladding not just back
non-top and then slate until that's only
raising it even more which is affecting
the neighbor even more in that respect
so I can't support approval of it yet
you're moving towards a separate
proposal
well I'll propose that it refused for
that for those reasons there's no I mean
how can you approve something that's
going to have a lavatory in there and
you don't even know what the drainage is
where's the sewers for it
yeah
can I just seek clarification that there
is going to be a Dollar Tree in there
because if it's not on the plans
are we
are we going down a red herring
Crosby
okay for metaphors say haven't I are we
being distracted
yeah and also would the cladding not
automatically be removed to to Batten
the garage Falcon Batman
surely that would be common practice you
wouldn't you wouldn't tile over cladding
I thought so
okay um so there's no toilet shown on
the plans but I think somebody made a
comment that there would be so I
answered that in the report
um I
believe you can convert a garage uh
and probably put a toilet in it without
planning permission anyway
and the Heights in the report are based
on the slate roof so it's not like
there's going to be extra based on the
measurements that are in the yeah so the
height stays the same
oh sure
and you're allowed to toilet so you
don't need to show drainage is that
right
into an out Building without the need
for planning permission and and one
would assume it would Connect into the
foul drainage provisions of the main
dwelling
so we don't need
it
I think the risk is here we don't we
don't have a toilet shown on the plans
so I think to refuse it over concerns
that there's insufficient drain had
shown would be risky as other members
have said that it's not shown on the
plans and it's not in the description we
have to go what's on the plans
yeah
our counselor sorry
cancer Pennington
we're following that discussion that I
like to propose that is refused on DMO
the immediate one DMO ones that without
looking it up because overlooking and I
would like to propose a refusal on that
ground
sorry
Leathers grounds for a refusal because
of uncertainty if there is a toilet or
not
I do want the refusal I refuse to be
lost so I'm now arguing the refuses
should be done on the m01 immunity
well we've got three proposals then I
mean unless you could knock on a second
there I mean unless counselor leather
wants to withdraw his proposal we've
joined together if possible
yes
yeah
and overlooking is my reasons
[Music]
to the top of their sheet as an
appropriate gauge spacing to take the
slaves and they reached out in place on
top of the Richer they're raising it
that's going to affect the immunity
there's even more raising it
yeah and
so we clear on the reasons for refusal
owners straight on the policy reason
that you're proposing a council
Pennington proposing on dm01 which I
think is the immunity overlooking effect
yeah
um so as the case I was said policy dm1
does set a very high bar the harm to
amenity has to be significant
overlooking I think the the
recommendation for approval includes an
obscure glazed windy day so your
officer's recommendation or advice would
be that an overlooking element to put
against policy dn1 would certainly not
be sustained at appeal you're then
looking at other elements of amenity
such as the scale of the garage or the
building being overbearing to the
neighbor now the case officers talked
through showing photos and again I just
want to emphasize the high bar that has
to be reached for conflict with policy
dmo1 and also for members just to be
mindful that a building could be erected
if it was two meters away from the
boundary up to four meters in height the
building before you at the which goes up
to 3.8 meters so I just wanted to
clarify that do you add the argument
further
um from the omo the immunity value the
window
the tops I think about eight inches of
the window it can be seen
over and above the neighbor's fence so
you see that window that's already there
and I'm worried about the nighttime use
as well because there will be light from
that window that will then impinge on
the neighbors own area and I think
there's also not a daytime use but
there's a nighttime use with a light
going on so I I would strengthen that
DML one on that reason as well because I
think there's still a ground for a DMO
one that puts at a fairly High a reason
to give that as the reason for refusal
Debbie refresh my memory I believe you
said that the height of the window is
going to be below the height of the
fence line and maybe we're looking at
say the catnip lintel
above if we go back to the photograph
um
yeah the agent has confirmed that that
window will be finished so that it's
below the hot top of the fence we'll
condition that in
I think that's more than
yeah okay but let's condition in that
the
the window
the glazed aspect of the window will be
below the current
height of the fence
you know I'm trying to negotiate I'm
trying to mediate a settlement here
because quite clearly
um there could be some
adjustments to the building which would
then become permitted development
and what we don't want to do is to
escalate things between a neighbor
dispute so if we can do all we can I'm
hearing the
the officer saying that
to refuse it
we may well have an unsustainable
position at appeal
let's try and make this work the best
way we can
I think we put the third one in that the
current glazed aspect of the window is
below the current
bench height
yeah
sorry could I just uh
yeah perhaps just to make things so kind
of like it you already had your approval
why didn't you add that to your preview
and see if your second uh will confirm
that Amendment rather than have free
separate
that will get confusing so I think um
councilor Gibson seconded your approval
so if he would be happy with that
yeah so if he's happy with that
Amendment then that leaves us with the
the two proposals
so we've got two
yes Terence the approval won first with
councilor hacketts and then
and then
Christy
councilor Gibson
cancer
[Music]
leather
Council a lot
sorry again councilor Pennington
Smith
councilor Wheatley against
that's two four and six against approval
so um chair because that there was a
Pacific motion for refusal we'll have
we'll go with the refusal
motion as well
clear on the reason
um because we've obviously discussed the
potential to condition with obscure
glazing having the window beneath the
fence and what the clear conflict with
dmo1 is as part of the recommendation
please counselor
right here I've got a green light here
last year
um I I'm sticking to DMO one
um overlooking and both daytime and
nighttime use by the light that will
come from the window by what was
demonstrated on the presentation so that
is my ground for the refusal
spiritual world
can we add
something about the height of the
character because I'm sorry yeah and I
think we need to put that in because in
our report the officer actually says
it doesn't fit with our policy
um oh thank you and I think that's
important and we have done this before
um I might probably goes back before
anyone else can remember but the gaiety
cinema in Ecuador
where it had to be reduced by a very
small
size but there's a lot of
contention about that and it has been
done before and I think we need to just
highlight it
as well
which is councilor 11 yeah okay
right is that all
go to the Rope
sorry yeah
you're voting for a feasal on the basis
of
dm01 and the height of the guarantee
yes
if you're against the application then
you're voting for for the resolution
proposal
yep
right so we are voting for refusal
em
yeah is that part of The Proposal from
councilor Pennington
okay thank you
thank you chair councilor Christie
councilor Gibson
councilor Hackett
councilor Haynes for
councilor leather or
councilor Pennington more
councilor Smith
and councilor Wheatley four
uh that was six full refusal and two
against refusal chair
s
I've just been to perform that we've
gone past three hours so can we have a
proposal and second of that we've
proceed with the meeting because we've
only got two items left proposing to
take a look we go beyond
pretty good
right so we go to
I have to number eight the appeals
decision which is on pages
8647 any comments on those
it was an interesting ones this time
no comment oh yes Captain Christie
again oh thank you
um thank you number 20.
uh the appellant suggests that occupiers
are dwellings in rural areas are
familiar with and less sensitive to
agricultural odors and the various odor
generating activities take place and I
accept that the latter may be the case
is that true or are royal members immune
to Smells I've never seen it before
written I'll let you know
okay
yeah
Right Moving swiftly on item number nine
cost of appeals there's no cost of
appeals to
numb all right yeah sorry about this
these costs on appeals can I ask that as
a standing item we get the figures
because whenever I've asked before it's
always oh it hadn't been decided yet
it's in the area of I would like to
actually see the figures because we had
one not long ago where uh we were told
we haven't got the figures yet could it
be a standing item that we do actually
get the figures and yeah
using a lag from when the decision is in
normal course
yeah that would be beneficial running to
all committee members to know that
um number 10 dedicated decisions agmb
148 149
11 planning decisions I'm looking at
council at the Columbus Zoo is going to
get his own back
so I go through Page by Page 150.
54.
56.
58 they'd be really busy the plans
Department 59
one
62.
64.
65. I won't do it well 66.
Oh Captain
it's the ones that are not alone always
interests me and I glad to see there's
no slurry stories in there at this time
but I do know this is two or three
agricultural barns etc etc and it seems
like it's quite hard for agriculture uh
businesses to get their stuff through
the planning departments just noted
I'm well aware of that coming out
um 170
and 172.
right item number 12 part two we've got
no closed decision no sessions so I've
got no idea what the time is so I
declare the meeting closed and I hope
that all the new councils to the
committee didn't find it too onerous and
we look forward to the next committee
meeting
okay